Guten morgen tim tim es ist jeden tag nur brexit day.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundertneunzehn vom ersten elften zweitausendneunzehn halloween ist durch und brexit ist na ja zumindest vorerst auch durch.
Brexit ist auch ein zombie.
Oh ja total der wird auch noch lange hinter uns her traben so oder so egal wie es ausgeht allerdings werden jetzt die karten nochmal neu gemischt und keiner weiß nach welcher methode und deswegen wird jetzt nochmal richtig spannend.
Bist du denn als tennis.
Zu halloween da hat er da der johnson ja tatsächlich meine halbwegs hat er geschafft sich nicht vollständig zu blamieren ein bisschen anstand zu beweisen,
in seiner abschieds rede an den burger das war schön das war schon ganz okay.
Dass er mit der tennisball maschine verglichen hat weil er immer irgendwie eine antwort hat.
Schon okay ich meine der hat's hingekriegt ohne dass der einmal in zuordnung rufen musste.
Das ist so ein pflege wie den johnson schon.
Er sich richtig zusammen gerissen hat er fast hätte es fast gezeigt dass er das.
Servus ja dass er sich danach mit dem thema auch nicht mehr beschäftigen muss von.
Wahrscheinlich hat er auch einfach nur der gesetze gesagt wo ey wir haben alle zu feiern es ist vorbei es ist vorbei wir sind nicht los mal gucken wir jetzt kommt.
Ja hier ist die netz politische tennisball maschine wir,
kann man hier auch ordentlich raus und weil wir heute so richtig langes programm haben mit ganz ganz ganz vielen themen haben wir auch verstärkung eingeholt die österreichische tennisball maschine.
Den thomas hallo.
Das ist meine zweite folge erst hier in der mitte.
Ganz ungewohnt dieses studium.
Wow das hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt aus der erinnerung gar nicht zusammenbekommen.
Ja mein drittes mal hier in diesen hallen und das zweite mal dass ich eine sendung aufnehme aber passt ja auch wir haben ja auch.
Ruhig öfter vorbeikommen.
Ja genau es hat dich nach berlin verschlagen und da haben wir die gelegenheit gleich genutzt und ja an denkwürdigen,
daten äh war die woche ja nicht am und wird sie auch nicht sein also internet ist jetzt fünfzig jahre alt.
Habe ich mal wieder festgestellt dass ich ein bisschen älter bin als das internet das internet kann.
Ich wollte gerade sagen wie war das denn.
Internet können wir gar nichts erzählen ja diese aufstrebenden dinge.
Wie war was damals.
Ohne internet damals.
Das kannst du dir gar nicht vorstellen.
Spielzeug oder was hattest du was du hast du dich beschäftigte.
Das ist eine gute frage ich kann mich erinnern.
Als kleiner junge in der straßenbahn gesessen zu haben und diesen zustand nicht über einen computer verfügen zu können in dem moment.
Als extrem unangenehm und unangemessen zu empfinden also das das ist.
Was erlaube.
Das was ich schon immer irgendwie echt scheiße und insofern würde ich sogar fast sagen haben sich die dinge etwas verbessert aber halt immer noch nicht in der geschwindigkeit wie's angemessen wäre,
ja also dieses dieser dieser ideal zustand den ich mir wünsche ich hoffe der den den den krieg ich überhaupt noch mit.
Da bin ich mir mittlerweile gar nicht so sicher wenn man sich unsere digitalen minister.
Ich hab schon überlegt also man darf ja keine witze machen darüber ne.
Worüber ich hab was also.
Katastrophe mauerfall ist auch dreißig jahre her.
Brexit war gestern quasi.
Ja das ist also also mir ich,
mich hätte das ja sehr sehr sehr überrascht wenn 's jetzt wirklich brexit gegeben hätte dieses ganze getrocknet und getöse,
das war ja alles nur taktischer allerdings jetzt geht's in die vollen jetzt haben sie sich halt entschlossen wahlen abzuhalten und damit ist.
Ja alles offen als ich bleibe natürlich bei meiner wette.
Du
Kann alles passieren jetzt jetzt wird's hardcore.
Gut bling will weile haben.
Und auch schon mal halber ausblick auf diverse sendung dieser themen dieser sendung,
das wird auf jeden fall eine schöne vorschau auf den schmutzigen wahlkampf nächstes jahr in den usa der schmutzige wahlkampf den wir jetzt in britannien erleben werden nächsten zwei monaten.
Ich sag dir nur eins zum die fünf euro wetteinsatz ne der fall natürlich dann verzug zinsen an.
Ich dachte ich könnte eigentlich auch schon mal einen fünfer kriegen für jede verschoben eine brexit deadline das wäre.
Ein bisschen teuer.
Das könnte teuer werden.
Ja oder für jede neue regierungsbildung in österreich also.
Denk würdig war übrigens auch dass ich doch.
Ach ja noch ein jubiläum ist alles total voll mit jubiläen.
Seit zweitausendelf tun wir uns das an acht jahre dreihundertneunzehn folgen.
Mit heute sozusagen.
Fünfzig jahre internet.
Was heißt denn das für unsere quote wann war jetzt das waren montag war das jetzt ne diesem montag.
Diesen montag.
Weil ich nur dreihundert achtzehn folgen durch acht jahre macht neununddreißig komma sieben fünf.
Okay das ist da muss man sich jetzt nicht für schämen.
Wir stellen uns sowieso nicht.
Das stimmt wir sind schamlos.
Wir sind ja wir haben ja anstand wir wollen uns nicht so schön ja als ich dessen.
Ein endes anstand die anderen ins schamlos zeit.
Ja es gibt ja schon einige die sich schön müssten so sehe ich nicht.
Ja zu fünfzig jahre internet wird natürlich gerade viel geschrieben und auch wenn gleich aus unserer perspektive da ist gar nicht so viel hinzuzufügen,
es kann ich eigentlich der jüngeren generation durchaus empfehlen wir haben auch ein paar links in unserer unseren shownotes zum nachkriegs.
Sich das mal so reinzuziehen wie das so war denn,
ist schon ist schon äh denkwürdiger entwicklung gewesen und ich erinnere mich auch immer noch wirklich an dem tag wo mir das erste mal so klar wurde so scheiße.
Die wollen jetzt unser internet zu dem internet machen als war lange lange zeit immer so dieses gefühl so.
Wählt ihr doch ja im internet und ihr wisst noch nicht mal dass es das gibt.
Der digitale untergrund.
Ja und auf einmal ging so die tür auf und irgendwie die welt standards sagte ah echt geil komm dann gehen wir jetzt mal rein und dann ist es so ein bisschen wie auf einmal irgendwie nur noch,
so vögel um dich drum herum die überhaupt nicht verstehen wo das alles herkommt und benehmen sich schlecht und.
Gibt es auch diesen schönen spruch irgendwie immer den.
Des of the next predigt sozusagen immer wieder so in,
wissen konversation nur hoch kam wenn die leute dann so,
die zukunft bedrohlich geschildert haben so ja jeden tag haben wir mehr leute die hier irgendwie erst letzten zwei monaten dazu gekommen sind als wir vorher insgesamt hatten und so das wird der untergang des netzes sein insofern hat sich das nicht ganz gut geschlagen aber es eiert.
Es eiert russland will jetzt irgendwie sich ab kapseln und china ist schon dabei also das sind alles keine schönen entwicklung.
Wir sehen tim war online bevor es cool war.
Vorher bevor überhaupt irgendjemand wusste dass man online sein konnte.
Du machst es hoch ihre alten mehr oder.
Ich hatte sich auch das ein oder andere verbessert das muss man auch sagen so ist es.
Ja es vielleicht ganz wichtig sich an dieser jungfräulich ideen des internets zu erinnern was die visionen waren am anfang also ich glaube so diese vision von zukunft hier das internet mal hatte die dürfen wir jetzt auch nicht vergessen
auch wenn sie ein bisschen schwerfällig ausschaut und so die pubertierende sturm und drang zeit schon vorbei ist.
Weiß aber die frage wen du fragst wer da welche vision vom internet gehabt hat ursprünglich das ganze im wesentlichen wirklich als wissenschaftliche akademischer und militärische austausch
gedacht gewesen und hat als solcher ja auch funktioniert und realisiert und erst als ebenso die nerds da so ein bisschen mit rein,
drücken und eben dem ganzen auch eine kultur beifügt und dann gab 's halt so eine kurze zeit der glückseligkeit
wo man dachte so oh geil hier guck mal auf einer diskussionsrunde raum und so ich weiß nicht ob ich das erste mal auf dem bildschirm gestartet hat dadurch sowieso mit space.
Nachrichten durchklicken und wunderte was was.
Was lese ich denn da eigentlich gerade was was ist denn das worauf ich da drauf schaue irgendwelche amerikaner schreiben ja irgendwas zu betriebssystem,
und das kann man alles noch komisch vor und dann schaut euch noch mal genauer hin und sah.
Diese nachricht vor drei tagen geschrieben war,
und das traf mich wieder blitz in dem moment also so vor drei tagen sagen damals wirklich 'ne mail hingeschickt dauerte das auch drei tage also die e-mail dauerte drei tage,
von meinem computer bis dahin weil die sich so von rechner zu rechner so mit,
telefon übertragung durch fressen musste,
aber drei tage war halt damals schon irre also es war irgendwie unfassbar ja wie konnte es sein dass eine nachricht so einen weiten weg und dann auf meinem computer landet.
Na ja heute ist aber schon genervt weil es dreißig millisekunden dauert.
Der du vor allem.
Ich war.
Komm her zum feedback ja oder,
andy schreibt uns etwas losgelöst aber ich denke die frage ist auf jeden fall ganz interessant weil sie mich relativ oft ereilt.
Wie kann man sich den staat zu jana eigentlich einfangen und wie kann ich mich generell schützen.
Zweitens was haltet ihr von us und verschiedene privaten direction remix.
Et cetera hatte mit einem kumpel ein streitgespräch über deren sicherheit und wir sind auf kein punkt gekommen.
Sollte man vorsichtig sein wer aus solchen systemen banking apps nutzt also da es ist tatsächlich so dass ich ungefähr.
Ich würde sagen gefühlt einmal im monat oder einmal alle zwei monate sich jemand bei mir meldet der vollkommen überzeugt ist mit dem staat jana infiziert worden zu sein,
und mir das dann auch schreibt von dem überwacht gerät ja.
Meine frage ist dann immer so welches schwere verbrechen hast du begann dass dich in die,
zielperson des staatstheaters flecken würde nichts nichts nichts mein gewisses rein aber die sind hinter mir her
es ist tatsächlich sehr unwahrscheinlich oder sagen wir mal so,
dein risiko lieber andi dass du mit einem staatsferne infiziert wirst ist dann doch einfach zahlenmäßig relativ gering.
Nur.
Das hängt von deinem.
Komm wir gehen davon aus dass wir hier keine kriminellen hörerinnen und hörer haben solange du nicht im bereich der schweren oder organisierten kriminalität unterwegs bist bist du heute noch,
einfach sehr sehr geringer wahrscheinlichkeit zielperson es ist nicht so dass das sich das erwischen wird was ich erwischt ist,
im zweifelsfall sowas wie vorratsdatenspeicherung tracking der scheiß wenn du bei google und bei facebook ein tipps,
oder auch einfach mal als e-mail anhang gesendet wird das sind alles risiken über die du dir vorher gedanken machen muss.
Du dir ernsthaft gedanken darüber machen muss
dass du dir den staatsferne ein fängst es soll ja auch zumindest zu sein da kommen wir später nochmal zu.
Dass du dir den gezielt einfangen würdest ist nicht irgendwie so als würdest du auf bundesregierung de gehen und plötzlich einen staats royale haben,
das ist nicht so willkommen auf das thema staatsferne im laufe der sendung nochmal aber deswegen wollte ich das hier an dieser stelle auch mal behandeln dann hast du eine reihe an android betriebssystem genannt
die größeren teil davon kenne ich nicht und ich denke da lautet einfach mal die das davon kriege ich glaube ich so ungefähr jeden zweiten tag eine nachricht
wo dann menschen mit irgendwas in der hand wählen dann ist das jetzt sicher oder ist dieses oder jenes sicher real.
Sicher ist erstmal die frage was es überhaupt deine bedrohung wovor hast du denn sorge es gibt ja relativ viele bedrohungen modelle.
Und wie sicher oder unsicher etwas ist was du benutzt hängt davon ab was deine bedrohung ist generell teilt man das auf in,
ja verfügbarkeit vertraulichkeit und integrität der systeme je nachdem was da jetzt das ist
mit dem du dich bedroht fühlst kannst du eben sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergreifen generell sind aber alle diese sicherheitsmaßnahmen eher dadurch gekennzeichnet dass sicherheit ein prozess ist viel mehr als ein zustand
und aus diesem grunde hängt es viel mehr davon ab wie du diese geräte betreibst und wie diese software die du da installieren möchtest gepflegt wird und,
ich würde wenn ich die,
wenn ich ein kriterium für die auswahl benennen würde würde ich darauf achten dass es eine sehr aktive.
Pflege des produktes gibt wo regelmäßig und zeitnah
updates stattfinden und diese auch herunterladen bar und installiert war sind da werde ich jetzt bei android erstmal wahrscheinlich nicht sofort
an der idealen adresse aber bevor jetzt hier glaubens kriege entstehen,
versuche eben dich an eine betriebssysteme,
gepflegt werden und die vielleicht auch von vielen leuten,
genutzt werden so dass da ein druck steht dass du da entsteht dass du da dauerhaft.
Dass es dauerhaft gepflegt und geprüft und weiterentwickelt wird.
Dann haben wir natürlich feedback bekommen auch zu unserer wiederholten debatte rund um wahl computer oder wollen sie verschiedene dinge aufgebracht.
Vielleicht mal so vorab nochmal so der kurze hinweis stand jetzt gerade hat die fdp.
Genau eine stimme,
mehr als erforderlich oder oder genau diese eine stimme die die erforderlich ist glaube ich also würde sie diese eine noch verlieren wäre sie vermutlich nicht mehr in den jetzt frisch gewählten landtag,
in thüringen sprich derzeit stehen sie bei fünf komma null null null fünf prozent geht in diese eine stimme verloren was durchaus noch passieren kann vielleicht auch nicht.
Sind sie irgendwie bei vier.
Und dann sind sie halt raus so und gut diskussion fünf prozent hürde hin und her das ist nochmal eine andere debatte existiert aber,
man kann also jetzt nicht gerade behaupten,
dass eine nachvollziehbar kalt und eine nacht zählbares mit einer wahl keinerlei nennenswerte bedeutung hat weil es natürlich den kompletten,
die ganze sitzverteilung nochmal neu durchmischt und in dem aktuellen koalitionspartner der läuft das sicherlich nochmal eine ganz interessante wendung wäre,
warum ich erwähne ich das jetzt weil unser argument bei wahl computern ja immer das ist das auch geringfügige
modifikationen schon problematisch sein können und die unmöglichkeit der durchführung einer geheime wahl und er nachvollziehbar kalt also.
Der kombination der drei wichtigen faktoren nachvollziehbar.
Daheim und dann im digital geht halt nicht zusammen,
wir haben ja hier ausführlich dargelegt.
Dass das eben uns immer noch ein sehr wichtiger punkt ist und wer auch immer noch denken da ganz richtig zu liegen.
Jetzt.
Wurde in dem zusammenhang mit dieser abstimmung um die vorsitzenden wahl diese urabstimmung bei der spd.
Das argument aufgebracht na ja das wäre ja sonst alles viel zu teuer dann könnte man das ja gar nicht machen.
Ja interessanter punkt ja,
natürlich ist es extrem verlockend zu sagen ah ja jetzt wo es sozusagen sich alles billig runter rationalität tieren lässt und man eben mit geringen kosten das online machen kann dann verzichten wir halt einfach mal auf
das was eigentlich eine wahl ausmachen sollte.
Ja naja gut also kann man so sehen die frage ist nur was ist denn jetzt hier wichtiger also ist sozusagen das grundprinzip einer wahl.
Hinfällig in dem moment wo es teuer ist und dann lässt man das halt einfach sein.
Sehe ich nicht ganz so und ich denke es gibt auch immer kreative wege wie man solche kosten auch reduzieren kann ohne jetzt hier den umfangreichen vorschlag zu machen wie es hätte auch gemacht werden können gesehen dass das online ganz wild,
diskutiert wurde in dem zusammenhang wurde dann auch nochmal drauf hingewiesen und da gibt's einen schönen kommentar von martino.
Das ist ja hier in diesem fall nicht um eine unwahrheit ging er schreibt,
die computer wahl ersetzt in diesem fall keine unfall sondern eine briefwahl,
eine briefwahl ist jedoch wieder geheim noch nachvollziehbar zumindest dann nicht wenn man ehrlich,
wie bei computer wahlen stellen bei einer briefwahl,
bei der bundestagswahl ist mein stimmzettel mit meinem namen verknüpft wenn ich den brief abschicken ich muss darauf vertrauen dass meine stimme im briefwahl büro hinreichend anonymisiert und dann auch korrekt gezählt wird dieser vorgang kann zwar beobachtet werden allerdings nicht von mir sonst hätte ich keine echte briefwahl gemacht,
genauso könnte man elektronisch ein gesamte wahlunterlagen behandeln und ja dann muss ich darauf vertrauen dass die hart und software korrekt arbeitet keine einsendung unterschied und manipuliert genau wie bei der post.
Ja also erstmal.
Hast du natürlich recht ja also briefwahl ist schon nochmal zu unterscheiden und bei dem auch von dir angeführten beispiele der bundestagswahl ist ja briefwahl zulässig.
Und ich gebe auch zu dass auch ganz praktisch weil man kann eben nicht unbedingt immer vor ort sein.
Jetzt hat das bundesverfassungsgericht allerdings auch festgestellt bei war das im rahmen der wahl computer.
Entscheidungen sogar auch noch mal explizit aber das separat das briefwahl sozusagen immer.
Nur dann wirklich als zulässig gelten kann wenn sie im rahmen gehalten wird also wenn das eben eine deutliche.
Geringere zahl ist der stimmen die abgegeben werden und der steigende trend von der so hin geht zur briefwahl ist in dem zusammenhang auch problematisch muss diskutiert werden.
Wo ich dir nicht ganz so zustimmen ist dieses einfache,
genauso wie bei elektronisch weil erstmal ist es so dass halt einen stimmzettel der mit,
mit einem post auf dem post weg geschickt wird und mit um schlägen arbeitet natürlich schon eine gewisse sicherheit in anführungsstrichen hat es halt,
verklebt damit versiegelt umschläge sind voneinander getrennt da steht an der name drauf und die briefwahl wird als solche erstmal akzeptiert aber eigentlich stimmzettel der dann entnommen wird und da schauen dann halt auch leute zu.
Der enthält dann diese information nicht mehr also der eigentliche stimmzettel ist dann anonym.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau weil jemand von euch schon mal in einem briefwahl prozess in irgendeiner form beteiligt vermute mal nicht aber es ist auch nicht so dass er nur irgendwie eine person sitzt.
Und ja also briefwahl ist,
an sich problematisch hat aber gegenüber dieser elektronische variante sehr wohl noch vorteile weil das mit dem vertrauen heißt ja hier in dem moment wo man den briefwahl prozess nicht vertraut vertraut man diesen menschen nicht.
Da sind halt mehrere leute beteiligt und auch dort gilt natürlich das prinzip das sich das beobachten lässt also ich denke was hättest sehr wohl die möglichkeit eine briefwahl auswahl briefwahl auszählung zu beobachten.
Ist natürlich das problem was ist wenn die post nicht ankommt und so weiter das sehe ich auch ist definitiv ein punkt,
aber und das ist der kern unterschied in dem moment wo software und hardware zusammenarbeitet um diesen ganzen prozess machen,
ist er halt auf eine art und weise manipulierbar wie man das eben bei post papier wahl.
Einfach nicht organisiert bekommt man kann strategisch,
manipulieren man kann zahlen ändern man kann prozesse ändern man kann einfach die stimmen selber ändern alles lässt sich manipulieren es lässt sich vor allem
algorithmus angepasst an die realität ändern also man erinnert mich einfach mal pauschal alles stimmt jetzt für meinen kandidaten sondern es reicht dann halt am ende genau diese eine stimme zu drehen die fdp jetzt noch gebraucht hätte und kein wird es jemals auffallen
weil es sich nicht nachzählen lässt.
Und das ist das problematische klar deine brief den brief kann verloren gehen aber dann weiß man halt nicht was da drin war.
Also zumindest ein vorteil,
aber in dem moment wo er entnommen ist beobachten dass mehrere leute landet der ohne und wird natürlich genauso gezählt und kann dann nicht mehr strategisch geändert werden also,
es bleibt schwierig und das zu dein feedback.
Ich habe auch sehr viel feedback bekommen hätten der süddeutschen zeitung nochmal erklärt habe
in einem interview warum das mit dem online-voting eine schlechte idee ist und ich habe daraufhin sehr viele kann konzepte zugenäht bekommen wie man online voting denn sicher durchführen könnte.
Lass mich raten da gibt es irgendein projekt bei und einer uni und.
Also es gibt eine reihe und ich hatte mir wirklich hier mehrfach versucht das zu betonen das es nicht um die sicherheit geht sondern um die nachvollziehbar zeit hat mir arnold ein konzept geschickt an dem ich jetzt mal beispielhaft erklären möchte warum
warum das wirklich keine so gute idee ist also arnold schreibt die urne sei ein fdp server,
oder sonst ein öffentlich einsehbar verzeichnis auf diesem server werden sozusagen verschlüsselte wahlbrief eingeworfen
der einwurf kann erfolgen entweder per e-mail der verschlüsselte wahlbrief wird von der e-mail getrennt wie beim briefe verfahren
durch eine scanner urne,
der physikalische walzer wird beim einwurf quasi gescannt und verschlüsselt auf den fdp server gelegt,
zur verschlüsselung wird jeweils der öffentlich hinterlegte pi pi wahl,
vorgang schlüssel verwendet,
der dazugehörige entschlüsseln skie liegt am besten bis zur schließung des wahlkampfs irgendwo auf einem in einem materiellen safe die urne bleibt also erstmal verschlossen bis zur auszählung geschritten wird.
Auf dem öffentlichen,
server liegen also erstmal nur datei die allesamt verschlüsse sind und nur der wähler selbst könnte sein wahlzettel entschlüsseln aber nicht,
den eines anderen wähler s da anhand des eingangs datums hinterher möglicherweise auf den wähler geschlossen werden könnte werden bei der schließung,
bis bald dir das einfach ist und ernährung der ohne alle daten mit dem gleichen datum versehen
auch das vollkommen transparent und öffentlich nachdem dies geschehen ist kann zur auszählung geschritten werden wenn alle daten öffentlich anonym genug,
also auf dem server liegen wird,
zur auszählung geschritten die lehrgang der urne erfolgt dadurch dass nun der entschlüsseln skier öffentlich gemacht wird und jeder die wahlzettel auch selbst entschlüsseln könnte beziehungsweise kann,
entschlüsseln ergebnis wird,
demselben server im moment der entschlüsseln wie quasi das entfalten des wahlzettel bei auszählung gelegt sodass jeder sofort sehen kann wann der zahl wahlzettel entschlüsselt wurde und was in ihrem stand
tja und der rest ist dann das zusammen addieren wie bei jeder anderen ohne auch zu unsicher.
Na oma paar schalke haben sie das verstanden.
Genau ja also erstmal lieber arnold das thema ist nicht dass es unsicher ist aber ich erkläre dir jetzt mal ganz kurz warum das wirklich eine also nicht nur warum das unsicher ist und warum es unsinnig ist.
Also fdp server du erinnerst dich eventuell an den heck des ähm.
Der bundestagswahl spezifisches ausbildungssystem ist in hessen,
wo genau das getan wurde nämlich wahlergebnisse auf einem fdp server zu sammeln den zugang zu diesem fdp server hatte.
Martin ja relativ schnell herausgefunden martin schiller sich und hat dort,
alle dateien die dort eingereicht wurden lesen schreiben und verändern können dieser fdp server bräuchte also entweder was weiß ich ich schätze mal es gibt irgendwie bundesweit sowas wie sechzig millionen wahlberechtigte oder fünfundsechzig.
Fünfundsechzig millionen nutzer die unter ihre eigenen user da was reinladen oder die benutzen alle den gleichen und können dann aber auch löschen.
Das heißt das geht schon mal nicht ähm zweitens verschlüsselte wahlbrief e ja,
schöne idee du sagst du musst also jetzt mit p gemacht werden ich habe gerade mal geschaut ein.
Üblicher gut vierter kieze war im
vernetz verfügt über so etwas wie sechs millionen kies die p in seinen wahrscheinlich fünfundzwanzig jahren oder über fünfundzwanzig jahren der existenz weltweit
auf diesen kiefern generiert hat wir würden euch hier also für einen massiven nutzer zuwachs für p sprechen wenn wir jetzt auf einmal.
So viele p hätten theoretisch könnte man verschlüsseln an an einen einzigen p und die leute,
verschlüsseln brauchen gar keinen eigenen da hast du allerdings leider ein kleines bisschen
mangelnde kennt ist das p verfahren oder insgesamt der asymmetrische verschlüsselung offenbart weil du hast nur die leute,
die quasi können ihre eigene wahl entschlüsseln aber nicht die der anderen nun das geht nur,
wenn du was pipi eigentlich automatisch tut das wahlergebnis
das heißt egal wie du da noch irgendwelche datei times verändert,
jede einzelne wahl stimme die da stattfindet wäre verschlüsselt an die wahlurne,
und an die person die die stimme abgegeben hat wenn sie die denn einsehen soll wenn das nicht so wäre dann wüsste sie nicht was sie da abgestimmt hatte könnt ihre eigene stimme nicht mehr wiedererkennen also beides funktioniert nicht.
Die das problem bei p ist eigentlich dass du,
also genau jetzt kommt er jetzt kommt der punkt es gibt irgendwie eine wahlbeteiligung von dreißig prozent oder so oder von mir aus auf vierzig prozent das heißt gibt sechzig prozent der leute die nicht gewählt haben ich könnte also einfach.
An diese leute und an die wahlurne verschlüsselt irgendwas auf den fdp server laden.
Und du hättest jetzt da stimmen in deiner urne wo völlig unklar ist wer die abgegeben hat.
Ähm das heißt dieses gesamte verfahren ist leider wirklich nicht unsicher sondern
wirklich unsinnig und es hilft halt auch wirklich nicht wenn leute die die verfahren nicht verstanden haben sich da irgendetwas ausdenken und wenn es leute tun die die verfahren verstanden haben dann versteht's immer noch niemand anders also es geht
einfach nicht und
dass ich will gar nicht erst damit anfangen was das bedeuten würde mit denen fünfundsechzigsten oder siebzig millionen die wir bräuchten die dann auch nochmal irgendwie authentische art werden müssten die ganzen signaturen hast du außen vorgelassen,
es geht wirklich nicht was du dir da ausgedacht hat und das ist ein beispiel von sehr vielen die mir zugenäht wurden es geht nicht
also abgesehen davon dass dieses verfahren katastrophal unsicher wäre und den einfachen test
kann jemand für eine andere person eine stimme abgeben nicht besteht würde es trotzdem schon keiner nachvollziehen können wie wir jetzt auch an unseren hörern merken die wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr wissen wovon ich überhaupt rede.
Ja da ich mit euch.
Steigt da aus also es ist einfach die komplexität wenn man sich auch nur mal ein bisschen mit fotografie beschäftigt und ich würde sagen ich fahre voll dieses feld ich habe mich da mal ein bisschen mit beschäftigt,
man steigt das sehr schnell aus weil einfach die ganzen im publikationen irgendwelcher maßnahmen sind so vielfältig und so unüberschaubar und selbst für experten immer wieder ein ordentliche ordentliche öl film auf dem man sich auf die schnauze legen,
wenn sie schon nach fünf minuten irgendwie die ersten zehn sachen auspacken.
Es ist halt einfach unsinnig und vor allem am ende was wird dadurch verbessert was.
Eigentlich besser als das was wir jetzt haben das ist überhaupt.
Ich will nochmal kurz das grundproblem sagen du kannst so viel verschlüsseln wie du willst das problem bei verschlüsselung ist nicht zu verschlüsseln sondern zu authentisch vieren sicherzustellen dass du an die richtige stelle verschlüsselt hast.
Und unter umständen in dem fall dieser wahl sicherzustellen dass jede person nur einmal gewählt hat damit also sicherzustellen dass du irgendeinen backbord hass zu erkennen dass es eine,
eine position eine person die wählen darf und die hat auch nur einmal gewählt.
Wir haben all das ist hier kinder lasst es sein.
Ich hab grad mein betriebssystem geupdatet es funktioniert wieder erstmal ein g erstmal wieder nicht für ein paar monate.
Willkommen in meiner welt hin.
Ja ja das war nur so nebenbei soll da sitzen sie die experten kriegen noch nicht mal ihre eigene e-mail schluss.
Ich kann dir also du kannst es noch also die speerspitze ganz ehrlich du kannst du kannst es noch über die commander benutzen.
Oh toll weil er kommt vor.
Na ja na ja du kannst ja auch also ich sag mal bei einigen für pkw in mut das heißt ja in einer so in drei vier stunden konfiguriert so dann kannst du ja weiter e-mail schreiben.
Aber linus wie kann denn das eigentlich sein.
Wenn sogar die gesellschaft für informatik online voting macht dann muss das doch gut sein.
Die gesellschaft für informatik die gesellschaft gegen informatik.
Simon weiß uns darauf hin die elektronische wahl nein siebenundzwanzig daraufhin dass auch die gesellschaft für informatik ihre vorstands wahlen und so weiter durchführt.
Und siehe da tatsächlich sie haben sich sagen sein online-voting dienstleister geklickt also kriegen das noch nicht mal selber programmiert sehr schön.
Da heißt es dann.
Theoretisch informatiker oder.
Also theoretisch funktioniert das.
Aber immerhin die könnte sagen sie haben auf jeden fall weiterfahren dass alle ihre mitglieder nachvollziehen also da könnte man nachvollziehen können man könnte da jetzt also sagen wie gesagt für die gesellschaft für informatik das macht
erfüllen die unter zumindest theoretisch die möglichkeit dass alle wahlberechtigten das
das eventuell nachvollziehen können das ist so eine nischen sogar sagen die.
Da ist es dann so schön die elektronische wahl funktioniert nach dem pin slash wahl pin prinzip,
als pin fungiert ihre mitglieds nummer die zugehörige sechzehn ständige wahl pin finden sie unter dem rubbeln fällt im wahl anschreiben.
Können sie doch einfach machen.
Ja eben eins nein das mussten aber auch irgendwie.
Gehen sie wie folgt vor sie benötigen eine pin in klammern mitglieds nummer.
Wie bei der spd weißt du übrigens wie viele,
wie viele spd-mitglieder listen ich irgendwie im post eingang hatte wo irgendwie sack weise
leute mit mit ihren mitgliedsländern standen weil die spd irgendwann mal wer übrigens eingeladen ist hier mit der mitglieds nummer dreiundzwanzig zweiundvierzig,
franken ort so lange listen.
Naja.
Genau also die pin ist die mitglieds nummer.
Die persönliche identifikation war die wahl pin alpha numerische kette unter fällt mit der eingabe von pin und wahl pin wird in der stimmzettel für die präsidium small angezeigt.
Ob sie die lehrzeit zwischen den vierer blöcken der wahl pin eingeben ist unerheblich oh sehr.
Sie sind der regulären ausdrücke mächtig.
Ja ja können richtig was passen hier damit wählen sie ihre kandidaten und geben ihre stimme ab bla also die gesellschaft für informatik ich weiß ja nicht was ihr sonst so macht.
Ach ja sehr schön dann am ende erscheint der hinweis vielen dank ihre stimme wurde gezielt danach schließen sie bitte das fenster und löschen ihren cash.
Und heizung aus.
Oh
Heizung auswärts dazu cash lernen.
Demokratie braucht ja auch rituale.
Sitzen sie danach zehn minuten schweigend auf dem sofa und trinken sie eine cola das ist alles so wieder so so so so sicherheit esoterik ja löschen sie ihren cash warum was ist wenn ich mein cash nicht löschen ja.
Also was ist das denn für ein unsinn ich meine ich habe doch der gesellschaft für informatik gerade gesagt wer ich bin und was ich wähle und was soll ich jetzt meinen cash lernen der haben sie den jetzt auch noch.
Ja nicht dass irgendjemand reinkommt der staatsregierung.
Leute echt wirklich also 'ne schande ist das gesellschaft für informatik bitte wirklich also das ist einfach dass das das kann nicht euer ernst sein.
Erstmal wenn ihr den leuten sowieso schon rubel felder schickt.
Alter dann sollen sie doch einfach die wahl an rubbeln.
Wieder ein briefkasten schicken und dann tragen sie auch das porto und fertig.
Gibt es auch mit rubbeln losen.
Ja einfach auslosen kommt wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch das gleiche raus so ja und wer zählt das dann dann zählt das halt der dienstleister,
julias wodurch ist das sicher na ja weil wahrscheinlich auf der webseite steht ist total sicher.
Völlig irgendwie wir sind vollkommen in tegel da und so keiner bezahlt uns ah nee doch die gesellschaft für informatik bezahlt uns
wer ist denn die gesellschaft informiert ja das ist der aktuelle vorstand der möchte gerne wieder gewählt werden da kann jetzt überhaupt gar keinen konflikt entstehen also.
Ist einfach aber weißt du was ich tatsächlich was was ich wirklich mit interesse feststelle es gibt so bestimmte themen also.
Bestimmte themen behandeln wir im logbuch da kommt einfach überhaupt gar kein feedback da wird der wird hingenommen keine ahnung weiß ich nicht,
vielleicht sagen sie vielleicht sagen die leute es gibt interessiert mich nicht oder sagen okay das war jetzt die die wahrheit und nicht zuletzt die reine wahrheit tiptop.
Und es gibt themen wo sich unmengen an menschen.
Bemüht sich fühlen mitzudiskutieren also riesige riesige fahrrad schuppen wie man sich bauen kann wo jeder mann 'ne latte lackieren möchte und,
ich frag mich warum ausgerechnet online voting sich da so zu eignet weil ich tatsächlich eigentlich der ansicht bin dass diese,
so digital nachvollziehbar und geheim lässt sich nicht kombinieren nehme anni nehme jede kombination aus zwei aber du bekommst nicht alle drei.
Was ich dir sagen warum.
Das ist so simpel und nachvollziehbar beziehungsweise vielleicht ist nicht nachvollziehbar.
Ist auch.
Aber warum wird warum eignet sich das so dazu dass alle möglichen leute da nochmal so ich hab 's.
Ich kann dir sagen der gedanke dass dass man was mit computer nicht lösen kann.
Er will dem gemeinderat nicht reingehen das
ist einfach das ist verletzte stolz weil man ja in seiner domäne meint so computer können alles ist einfach nur eine frage der richtigen richtigen ansatz ist und der programmierung und überhaupt da müssen einfach richtige helden ran und dann läuft das auch schon,
und das funktioniert hier halt einfach nicht und deswegen können die auch immer wieder gegen die wand.
Ich finde es so spannend weil von all den themen unserer demokratie wo wir gerade irgendwie gehirne brauchen könnten die sich um problemlösungen bemühen ist das halt einfach das eine der,
an
Zeitverschwendung.
Aber ich habe euch ein beispiel mitgebracht wo wahl computer sinn machen,
und das ist in parlamenten,
ähm also in österreich gab's nämlich grade einen schönen fall in österreich im nationalrat wird abgestimmt durch aufstehen also wenn du,
dann stehst du auf alle sitzungen des nationalrat sind öffentlich du kannst dich da auf die besucher tribüne stellen und in vielen dieser sitzungen gibt es auch eine live über
tagung ein da gab's halt jetzt im freien spiel der kräfte österreich hat ja gerade irgendwie so eine komische politische situation eine abstimmung die gar nicht so unwichtig war nämlich über das verbot der rechtsextremen identitären bewegung
und da war es so dass eine abstimmung wo relativ viele abgeordnete schon den saal verlassen hatten wurde davon ausgegangen dass dieses verbot der identitären
nicht angenommen wurde und dann hat aber die,
mehreren jahren schon fotografen sitzen der abfotografiert wie die aufstehen und dann,
eine wirkliche sozusagen digitales abbild davon macht wer jetzt wie abgestimmt hat.
Und die sind drauf gekommen da hat sich die fpö parlaments präsidentin vertan bei dieser abstimmung
und eigentlich wäre dieser antrag angenommen worden und die identitären wären verboten gewesen in österreich hat aber niemand bei einstand deswegen sind sie es nicht nur das ist der.
Boah.
Wird nicht kann nicht wenn's nicht beanstandet wird gilt das was die parlamentspräsident sagen in dem moment wenn sie die abstimmung auswerten an deswegen sind die identitären weiterhin eine legale vereinigung in österreich.
Gott.
Ich meine ich widerspreche dir nicht das ist ja keine geheime wahl.
Das ist ja keine geheime wahl ja das also,
im eu-parlament ist es ja auch tatsächlich gang und gäbe dass ihr diese kleine box haben wo sie drücken müssen und dann wenn es um ablaut filter gibt weil wir welche schweden waren das da irgendwelche schweden haben achso scheiße die sind ja zeile verrutscht oder so ne.
Die haben um zehn zehn stimmen haben sie nachher noch korrigiert und um fünf stimmen haben wir ablaut filter leider verloren und das ist wirklich also die gesamte arbeit von abgeordneten besteht darin diese drei knöpfe zu drücken ja nein enthaltung.
Sie haben dann halt einen hand eine hand auf den drei knöpfen und eine andere hand gehen die halt in der zeile durch wo dran steht was sie drücken müssen ne.
Aber.
Das ist ja interessant.
Das könnte man das nicht einscannen und offene fdp server land.
Wie wird denn das eigentlich überprüft.
Im europaparlament also dort ist es so dass du eben ein elektronisches abstimmung system hast jeder abgeordnete hat seine karte die ihr dort reinsteckt und damit
erst dieses terminal autorisiert du hast doch keine fixen sitzplätze,
und dann hast du die drei knöpfe zu jedem jeder abstimmung kannst du nur eine dieser drei optionen wählen
und du hast direkt nach der abstimmung dann auch anhand der,
sitz platzes im plenum genau eben wer,
abgestimmt hat also wenn du ein foto machst davon hast du sofort in dem moment das ergebnis der abstimmung
und es gibt dann im protokoll was im europaparlament innerhalb von wenigen stunden nach dem dem plenum samstag kommt auch wirklich nahe möglich nochmal genau ausgeführt wer die abgestimmt hat
abgeordnete können glaube ich für vierundzwanzig uhr achtundvierzig stunden ihre ihr abstimmung ergebnis ändern,
aber das kann nicht dazu führen dass das gesamte ergebnis der abstimmung sich ändert
also da auch wieder muss bei einspruch werden wenn das noch läuft und dann können sie doch mal abziehen und nochmal abstimmen.
Man kann für etwas stimmen aber danach behaupten man hätte nicht dafür abgestellt.
Genau wenn du dich vertippt hast kannst du sozusagen ehren rettung betreiben und deinen namen nochmal.
Aber das ist halt auch augenwischerei weil es nicht das endergebnis ändert.
Ja und da gibt's keine geheime abstimmung.
Gibt es also im österreichischen nationalrat weiß ich dass es die gibt es gibt auch namentliche abstimmungen wo sie dann so korrigiere mit ihrem namen in einer box werfen.
Ich mache jetzt mit diesem elektronischen system.
Beim europaparlament ist eine gute frage ich hab dort noch nie eine doch es muss geheime abstimmungen geben zum beispiel über die kommission kandidatinnen wird geheim abgestimmt.
Und da wird aber ein zettel genommen.
Ich weiß ich glaube dass das mit ohne ist ja.
Ja ich habe da zuletzt eben fotos gesehen wir kommen ja noch zu dem kommission leiten an der davids glaube ich mit papier und ohne gemacht.
Na gut also ich denke wir haben das thema damit auch ein weiteres mal über gebühr bedient aber wir sind also meinetwegen denkt euch noch irgendein scheiß aus.
Das macht in gewisser hinsicht auch spaß den ball immer wieder der tennisball maschine um die ohren zu hauen da können wir auf jeden fall gegen halten.
Oder.
So jetzt sind wir bei den themen.
Der richtigen themen.
Ja sehr.
Interessant war die nachricht dass whatsapp gegen die group klagt das ist ein sehr interessanter fall und zwar hat whatsapp im mai diesen jahres eine schwachstelle,
identifiziert und diese schwachstelle beseitigt es ging dabei im weitesten sinne darum dass du.
Also wenn wir uns schon so einen messenger anschauen
als applikation der hat ja an an bestimmte,
wo du mit dem in interaktion treten kannst also eine nachricht sendest oder einen anruf machst dann
im weiteren fall wenn er diese nachricht verarbeitet ja könnte sein dass er in der verarbeitung der nachricht irgendwelche fehler macht oder schwachstellen hat und
so das übelste was du dir vorstellen könntest wäre eine schwachstelle die auslöst bar ist ohne jede interaktion der nutzerinnen.
Und genau das hatte whatsapp nämlich in ihrem quasi in dem in dem protokoll was für telefonate,
verwendet wird du konntest quasi ein paket senden was von whatsapp von der applikation dann als ein anruf in abwesenheit,
gewertet oder angezeigt wurde darin hattest du aber die möglichkeit durch eine spezifisch formulierte es paket
dieses whatsapp zu übernehmen und damit eine code auszuführen auf dem ziel gerät mit anderen worten so die
ja leider die schwerste schwachstelle die ein system haben kann nämlich remote code exekutiven ohne irgendeine interaktion.
So hat whatsapp identifiziert und geschlossen im mai zwanzig neunzehn jetzt haben sie ende oktober.
Diese sache untersucht und haben quasi,
würde jetzt argument würde jetzt vermuten sie haben in ihren looks geschaut wer denn unter umständen diese angriffe,
oder diese schwachstelle ausgenutzt hat für angriffe und haben dann insgesamt so etwas wie eintausend vierhundert fälle identifiziert.
In denen diese schwachstelle ausgenutzt wurde und haben in,
einigen einzelfällen mit der hilfe des city die menschen identifiziert.
Das heißt hat damit zusammengearbeitet.
So klingt es mir ja ich habe da eine längere mail noch von dem head of ich weiß nicht genau wie die wie die werden sich an wen gewendet hat aber sie haben auf jeden fall zusammengearbeitet und,
jetzt ist es.
Jetzt hat halt whatsapp diese angezeigt ist ein israelischer es unternehmen das staatsferne
herstellt und zwar ziemlich genau so wie,
das kennen aber wie es auch,
dass sie quasi staatsstraße jana service anbieten die geben nicht,
wirklich diesen spaß komplett aus der hand.
Sondern machen halt fertige infektionen plattformen und stellen die in den dienst der staaten für die sie arbeiten
jetzt ist es natürlich so dass der dass sich wenn man guckt was mit welchen leuten city leb so arbeitet ne da geht's dann eben bis zu schnell irgendwie bei jamal
khashoggi ne der damals infiziert wurde von dem bekannt war dass sein telefon infiziert wurde mit
aus dem hause da haben wir auch damals schon.
Vorträge auf dem kongress zu gehabt zu der pegasus.
Also hier geht es sehr häufig nicht um,
menschen die irgendwo in der nähe von terrorismus stünden sondern regelmäßig um menschen die im rahmen der freiheitsbewegung stehen anwälte journalistinnen und sonstiges.
Und whatsapp hat jetzt die verklagt,
und zwar haben sie gesagt also haben interessante punkte da sind nämlich sagen naja um diesen fake call zu senden um dieses,
craft packet an die nutzer zu senden brauchtest du account.
Und die haben das ja getan,
und haben damit dann gegen die agb verstoßen weil hacking ist nord laut in whatsapp,
so das ist auch ein verstoß gemacht außerdem sagt whatsapp natürlich relativ klar pass auf.
Wenn wenn es eine schwachstelle gibt,
dann habt ihr eine moralische verpflichtung gegenüber den nutzerinnen und nutzer die zu melden und nicht die auszunutzen erst recht nicht,
in dem kontext eines geschäftsmodell ist ja also euer spezifisches geschäftsmodell ist es schwachstellen in unserer software,
zu finden auszunutzen zum schaden unserer nutzer und,
außerdem eben dadurch das nicht melden der schwachstellen daraufhin zu bewirken dass diese scharf stellen auf allen unseren systemen oder auf den systemen aller nutzer und whatsapp hat ja milliarden nutzer wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also weit mehr als diese über tausend personen die da getan hätte hat wobei man bei über tausend personen auf fragen könnte wie targeting das noch sein kann ja,
sieht ja schon ein bisschen nach schleppen netz fischerei aus.
Und ja whatsapp hat jetzt eben eine klage rum die group
wäscht ihre hände natürlich in unschuld und sagte dann haben wir nichts mit zu tun warum wir nicht wir haben hier strenge moralische regeln nachdem wir dieses theater veranstalten und alles nur im rahmen der,
unsere ethische regeln und der rechtlichen regeln der unrecht starten,
das ist mal relativ spannend und hier sehen wir eben sehr das sind wenn du jetzt heute dieses,
in dieser welt heute staatstragende haben möchtest von mobiltelefone dann gehst du zu oder zu den fischer ich weiß gar nicht aus hacking team noch gibt,
ja da müsste ich nochmal nachschauen und da sehen wir jetzt einen spezifischen fall von wie diese unternehmen agieren die,
von vielen staaten dieser erde und so ja auch die diskussion von deutschland mit geld versorgt,
werden das ist also ein genau das beispiel von dem wir immer sprechen dass wir sagen wir,
sprechen uns dagegen aus.
Das schwachstellen von solchen unternehmen geheim gehalten werden oder solche unternehmen überhaupt eine motivation ein anreiz bekommen das zu tun noch dazu sehen wir eben wie hier,
die alle möglichen leute angegriffen hat mit diesem zeug garantiert keine,
terroristen sind regie regierungs mitarbeiter und journalistinnen und anwälte also völliger völliger ihr sind,
im prinzip ist es mal echt interessant jetzt wirklich kein freund von whatsapp oder facebook aber dass die hier.
Dass die hier,
dieses ding dann halt auch einfach mal auf die internationale ebene heben und auf die juristische ebene heben ist nicht schlecht zumal das wahrscheinlich auch ganz schön ist die haben ja wahrscheinlich nicht die schlechtesten anwälte.
Vielleicht ganz passend dazu finde ich für uns noten den wir da verlinken
work vor der nase
finde ich finde ich ganz gut ich meine das ist ein bisschen blauer der leute zum bissel blonden motivieren will was was man irgendwie ganz schön ist aber dann auf der anderen seite ich meine diese servus also die haftung von einzelnen mitarbeiterinnen von solchen unternehmen
da sind wir jetzt auf jeden fall noch nicht und es wäre auch irgendwie schwierig dass über die restriktionen hinweg
umzusetzen aber es geht auf jeden fall schon mal in die richtung also dass man überhaupt jetzt mal leute die unsicherheit das geschäftsmodell haben so ins rampenlicht setzt ist auf jeden fall ein schritt in die richtige richtung.
Leider ist übrigens auch aufgefallen bei dem thema das ist ja was am ende tatsächlich bei den leuten hängen geblieben ist so whatsapp ist unsicher oh mein gott,
ich hatte dann auch ein radiointerviews mehrere interviews mit holgi vielleicht bei einigen podcasts podcasts hörerinnen und hörern auch bekannt
wo auch natürlich die frage welche messenger nehme ich denn stattdessen naja,
die gleich also im prinzip die gleiche schwachstelle gab es ja auch in eine message ja wir hatten eigentlich jetzt fast alle messenger durch,
alle weit verbreitet muss solche schwachstellen gab entscheidend ist nicht,
also natürlich ist es problematisch dass diese schwachstellen gibt aber ich kann heute nicht sagen welche schwachstellen morgen irgendwo entdeckt werden.
Die frage ist wie viel mühe geben sich die unternehmen deine,
rechte zu schützen und gegen solche vorzugehen und.
Ich bin da sehr angetan davon dass die komplett arsch gepudert millionär s anwälte von facebook jetzt mal sagen alles klar wir haben einen kleinen brief an euch geschrieben lass mal gucken wie wir hier weiterkommen,
und das find ich tatsächlich gut da kann ich facebook facebook applaudieren zu diesem schritt.
Kommen wir zum nächsten thema facebook.
Mark zuckerberg musste,
eine anhörung zu seiner kryptowährung libra im.
Kongress über sich ergehen lassen.
Also dem amerikanischen.
Bei unserem kongress.
Eine anhörung wir könnten eigentlich auch mit der content der kongress könnte vorlagen.
Ja ganz gut.
Erstaunlicherweise mehrere ausschnitte aus dieser anhörung kursiert ein sehr auf twitter und gingen dort viral unter anderem wie.
Alexandra cortese in verhört hat.
Also die bewertung die also einmal die allgemeine bewertung auf twitter schien zu sein die hat es ihm aber gezeigt wie ist eure meinung.
Ich fand das sehr gut ähm sie sie ist halt wirklich begabt darin leute zu grillen und
schafft es in diesen verhören oder anhörungen auch wirklich gut die themen rüberzubringen also den missstand aufzuzeigen
bei der konkreten sache hier geht es ja darum dass wenn politische werbung geschalten wird,
da hat vielleicht auch andere standards an meinungsfreiheit gelten und facebook stellt sich ja immer auf den punkt das sind alles nur aussagen die andere tätigen über unsere plattform wir machen uns die nicht zu eigen aber wenn du geld dafür zahlen dass diese aussagen durch facebook ganz spezifische leute erreichen
dann braucht es vielleicht andere standards dafür.
Also spezifisch nur um den übergang zu können will eigentlich war die spart die rede von libra und sie spricht halt über die ethischen standards von facebook und sagt pass mal auf ich bin monik ort ist ja so
kann ich eine werbung schalten in der ich von republikanischen gegenkandidaten behauptet sie hätten für meinen green judith gestimmt
was eine falsche aussage wäre und dann windet sich zuckerberg und sagt na ja es kommt ziemlich drauf an.
Und zwar kommt es was er sagen möchte es kommt darauf an ob du das sagst oder nur die werbung.
Wenn es nur die werbung sagt dann wird die zurückgezogen wenn du es sagst als world leader oder personen von politischen interesse dann würden wir es
stehen lassen weil du darfst lügen das ist das was er sagen möchte sie lässt ihn aber nichts sagen,
ich finde tatsächlich diese gesamten dieses gesamte theater da
in diesem in diesem kongress anhörungen wenn jetzt mehrere szenen draus angeschaut
die sind da unter ihrem zeitdruck und jedes mal wenn er überhaupt nur eine längere antwort geben möchte unterbrechen sie ihn sofort und sagen my time und stellen ihnen wie die nächste frage ja sagen aber du darfst du mit ja oder nein antworten
das ist ehrlich gesagt also da mache ich jetzt nicht ein vorwurf aber diese kultur der befragung sein ich völlig für 'n arsch
ja was soll das denn wenn sie ihre impeachment thüringens genauso machen musst du dich nicht wundern ja also entweder du lädst da jemanden vor um informationen zu gewinnen oder du lädst jemanden vor um den irgendwie die ganze zeit ins wort zu fallen
und und irgendwie deine meinung um die ohren zu hauen sie hat natürlich ein po also sie hat,
natürlich einen punkt auf den finger in die wunde gelegt aber diese kultur finde ich völlig daneben muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das ist jetzt nicht ihre schuld das ist in in allen anderen anhörungen auch so dass sie im prinzip kommt der da hin,
um und kann sich dann wenn dann eine abgeordnete da ihre fünf oder drei minuten zeit hat haben die redet die person die ihn gefragt,
vier minuten fünfundvierzig,
unterbrochen von kurzen stamm allein und so weiter irgendwie dazu ansetzt etwas zu sagen wird er sofort unterbrochen oder sowas also keine ahnung fische wenig.
Na ich finde wenn man nicht an eine frage gestellt bekommt dann kann man es vielleicht auch mal mit ja oder nein beantworten so
die wollen sich halt immer rausreden und immer um eier immer relativieren
und ihr gelingt es halt zumindest die sagt man so schön diese diskrepanz hat diese chrissy ganz gut rauszufiltern dieses ja sind jetzt lügen okay oder nicht und.
Dadurch dass er darauf keine klare antwort geben gibt und wahrscheinlich nicht geben kann ist halt auch ein ein politischer punkt gemacht und darum geht's ja letztlich.
Ja also ich es mag sein ich will.
Also ich verstehe dein punkt so und hast du auch recht das format ist problematisch.
In dem rahmen indem es nunmal existiert ist das eine ganz kluger umgang mit der zeit weil was ja auch was wasser sonst für euch erzählt wird insbesondere wenn die republikaner anfangen was internet zu reden.
So ich erinnere nur an die anhörung die zuckerberg im senat hatte
da war auf jeden fall ein breiteres format oder konnte man auch wirklich in die tiefe gehen an der preis für die schlechteste zuckerberg anhörung wird an der stelle für ans europaparlament weil da konnte sich bei allem rausfinden und das hat auch nur insgesamt glaube ich eineinhalb stunden gedauert.
Okay das ist natürlich ein das äh ist ein punkt ich würde nur weißt du wenn der dann irgendwann anfängt zu schwitzen und
sich die krawatte lockert oder so an den weil er irgendwie zum stress ausgesetzt ist und dann leute auf twitter ebenso dem hat es aber gegeben sorry das ist nicht das thema der auseinandersetzung.
Glaube worauf sie eigentlich aus ist ihn in so einem kritischen zustand zu bringen das hat zwischendurch geboten muss.
Das ist einfach so komplett freeze also drei sekunden lang.
Drei sekunden dann wird sie länger reden kann.
Ich nehme jetzt gerne ihre fragen entgegen.
Der alte zuckerbrot ist auch wirklich echt.
Warum das ist nicht nur eine menschliche frisur zu setzen.
Ist ja nicht nur die frisur es ist alles irgendwie also data hat er gut geklaut bekommen.
Interessant ist dass diese also über die libera anhörung inhaltlich wird weniger gesprochen als dann eben über das thema was ist
bei falsch aus politischen falsch aussagen falsch aussagen in politischer werbung und sonstigen und dann kommt
ritter der meinungsfreiheit jack ceo von twitter und sieht so einen richtigen moment und sagt übrigens.
Während des bewerben also generell werbung im internet unglaublich mächtig ist und sehr effektiv für kommerzielle anwendungen.
Hat diese macht und diese kraft enorme risiken im bereich der politik,
weil es dort weil sie dort benutzt werden kann um andere menschen zu beeinflussen und somit auch die wahl und somit auch millionen von menschen zu beeinflussen und deswegen sag twitter,
wir machen keine politische werbung fertig da gerät natürlich also jack dossier hat in den usa auch nicht den besten ruf.
Aber jetzt kann er genau mit diesem schlechten ruf echt mal seinem.
Konkurrenten mark zuckerberg echt mal rein grätschen.
Ich glaube allerdings da habe ich von lorenz mazza ein auch verlinkt er sagt er prognostiziert,
der ben von politischer werbung auf twitter wird ähnlich back feiern wie facebook sein scheidung zu politischen ads weil sich twitter dazu auf schwingt bestimmen zu können was politisch ist zum beispiel,
wer bestimmt wie was von nationaler wichtigkeit ist oder nicht also dadurch dass sie sagen es gibt keine politische ads.
Wird halt darin wird halt wird es wege geben diese regel zu umgehen ähnlich.
Wie also sie sie definieren im prinzip okay politische ads sind also werbung die für eine die zu einer bestimmten wahl oder einen bestimmten kandidaten.
Oder zu einem bestimmten legislativen thema von nationaler wichtigkeit.
Handeln und das heißt oder davon haben jetzt heißt natürlich trotzdem kann zum beispiel sowas wie sagen wir mal die.
Welt liga gegen abtreibung.
Werbung zum thema abtreibung schalten und damit.
Indirekt werbung zu für bestimmte kandidatinnen und kandidaten machen also das problem bei sowas ist.
Die definition und die wird bei twitter genauso schwierig sein aber als person ist es auf jeden fall schon mal schön und als statement da draußen ist es auch sehr schön dass das twitter das gemacht.
Es sind sind so ein paar sachen die man hier auseinander dröseln muss und das ähm also,
wenn man zurückgeht also diese frage von von facebook im im kongress ja also ob falsch aussagen die basis von politische werbung sein dürfen da ist schon die frage irgendwie so wer wer tritt diesen wahrheit beweis an.
Also ist das facebook die dann irgendwie vorab
überprüfen sollen ob dieser inhalt den fakten entspricht ja wenn das jetzt ein nicht falsches datum der wahl ist ist es noch vergleichsweise einfach wenn es aber um politische aussagen geht,
das wird es um welten schwieriger da einen einen wahrheit beweis an,
treten und auch mal falls man das gerichtlich klären will ist auch die frage so wer hat er den boden of
das das ist nicht so trivial und gerade auch jetzt mit dieser entscheidung von von twitter wenn man sich das anschaut wenn es um kandidatinnen geht ist es noch einfach aber wenn es dann um themen die von nationaler wichtigkeit sind da kannst du einfach nicht sagen
dass du anhand der werbe diese entscheidung treffen kannst um etwas politisches oder nicht sondern das muss der jeweilige werbe,
an der da geprüft wird und dadurch.
Du automatisch in der frage okay gut wer,
wer macht diese kontrolle wird die vorher nach gelagert und am ende halt auch verhaftet ja und im endeffekt glaube ich aber schon dass da eine lösung möglich ist indem du halt einfach auch 'ne verantwortlichkeit einfließt für inhalte die du,
die du als werbung
und das ist da halt einfach auch eine vorgelagerten kontrolle braucht ob diese werbungen den inhalt den richtlinien entsprechen und im zweifelsfall hat auch einfach nicht erscheinen dürfen
also werbung ist ja bei gott nichts was so wichtig ist für unsere gesellschaft dass wir dem keine grenzen setzen dürfen.
Meine,
sicherlich kann man jetzt ins klein klein gehen und sagen das ist schwierig weil wir das beurteilen et cetera aber dadurch das wetter ist so,
generell statement sagt und erstmal das ganze grenzenlos aufzieht es ja jetzt nicht nur in usa es geht ja weltweit sie sagen halt einfach,
wenn politisch dann nein so und das ist schon 'ne relativ stark aus wahl weil das bedeutet dass eigentlich ein unternehmen,
so wie vielleicht weiß ich nicht wer letzten endes der beauftragen der identität war letztlich aber irgendwo eine,
organisation oder vielleicht auch eine decke umgesetzt wird
ein einzelnes unternehmen jetzt auf einmal anfängt hunderttausende wenn nicht sogar millionen von solchen tweets die dann irgendwann schon mal auffallen dass es hier ja wohl ganz offensichtlich um die wahl politik geht
wenn die damit halt anfangen dann ist hier business halt auch sofort am ende das heißt die können schon ihren kunden gegenüber überhaupt gar keine zusagen mehr machen,
das ist das was sie da verkaufen auch wirklich abnehmer findet von daher ist dieser prozess dann doch schon signifikant.
Natürlich wird es jetzt möglich sein dass irgendwelche lobbyorganisation hier und da nochmal was rein,
werfen und vielleicht wird dann mal ein einzelner tweet gesperrt aber wir wissen alle dass es auch nicht übertreiben dürfen weil sie hat im zweifelsfall ihre eigene präsenz für ihren ureigenen anliegen damit natürlich auch gefährden also ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass das 'ne wirkung hat vielleicht,
da wird sicherlich wieder irgendwas durch sie kann ne wie heißt es so schön hundertprozentige sicherheit gar nicht geben mein lieblingsplatz und.
Da wird dann auch wieder nachgebessert werden aber sie sind jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal auf einer ganz anderen spur als facebook,
die sich halt immer noch so auf dem drogen parkplatz rumschlagen und sich quasi kohle von allen seiten zu stecken lassen und in der lage sind halt,
die ganzen mittelchen weiter zu reichen und der druck wird steigen dass sie mindestens eine,
naja aus ihrer perspektive vergleichbare initiative machen mit qualität level oder keine ahnung weil das kam auch wiederum in dieser,
kurze diskussion glaube ich mit auto c ganz gut zur sprache er fase tja dann schnell von meinungsfreiheit,
haben wir ja auch schon mal woanders gehört und das ist irgendwie.
Das trägt so dünn auf mittlerweile dieses ganze gefahr sind mit meinungsfreiheit weil eigentlich alle wissen dass meinungsfreiheit einfach immer nur so ein bisschen die ausrede ist für ja ich will einfach auf jeden drauf schlagen können der mir nicht passt und,
geht das ja auch in amerikanischen kultur langsam soweit dass man sich denkt so vielleicht sollten wir doch grenzen haben wo das stattfindet.
Er sagt aber er macht halt schon auf dem punkt macht.
Zuckerberg dass er nicht ich glaube nicht.
Wir diejenigen sind die am ende über wahrheit und unwahrheit entscheiden sollten.
Dafür haben sie ja ihre fact checker da die reihenweise vom schiff gehen weil sie keinen einfluss.
Nee sollten sie auch nicht aber das tut zum beispiel twitter ja auch nicht wenn man mit ihrer definition
geht da sagen sie ja nicht irgendwie bus wahr sein oder unwohl sein sondern einfach nur wenn es sich auf wahl und ein großes thema der wahl bezieht oder auf kandidaten dann nein
so und das ist eigentlich 'ne ziemlich coole ansage findet.
Ja
lässt allerdings natürlich diesen hebel offen in das donald trump und twitteraccount hat für den er nicht bezahlen muss und das,
hier cambridge analytica eben auch,
sage beton ja immer wieder das eigentliche vergehen von cambridge analytica war der verstoß gegen facebook agb sie hätten dafür bezahlen müssen für das was,
getan haben nämlich das
herauslesen dieser daten das haben sie nicht getan also da in einem in dunkel zu agieren ist nicht ausgeschlossen apropos
cambridge analytica das nur am rande dafür hat facebook jetzt in,
großbritannien eine strafe bekommen von.
Fünfhunderttausend britischen pfund.
Sechshundert hier komm.
Reden wir nicht weiter drüber.
Fünfe gerade sein lassen ja facebook erkennt die erhobenen vorwürfe nicht an,
erklärt sich aber dennoch zu der zahlungen bereit ja also ohne ohne eine erkenntnis einer rechts licht hat facebook jetzt einfach mal gesagt hier kommt geht uns nicht weiter offen sagt ihr habt eure fünfhunderttausend pfund das sind nach der derzeitigen rest wert des funds
fünfhundertneunundsiebzig tausend euro wenn du dir überlegst was ein brexit kostet ja sind sie da eigentlich echt ganz günstig von aus der nummer rausgekommen.
Ist allerdings auch nur eine datenschutz ein datenschutz bußgeldbescheid vom oktober zwanzig achtzehn wo es eben darum geht das.
Cambridge analytica ja die daten der facebook kunden extra hirte hat obwohl das eben ohne das interesse nicht im interesse der kunden war und facebook sich davor zu schützen müssen,
facebook hat damit ein verlust jahresumsatz von.
Jahres gewinn jahres gewinn von zweiundzwanzig milliarden us-dollar im jahr zwanzig achtzehn haben sie jetzt so mit einem gewinn verlust von null komma null zwei neun prozent da werden also jetzt harte.
Einsparung auf die facebook mitarbeiter zu kommen.
Kein speist am kinn mehr eben frühstücks kaffee.
Ja gut über diese ganzen infos mechanismen müssen wir uns eh noch mal gedanken machen weil auch wenn irgendwie milliarden strafen verhängt werden für das ja nur dazu dass der aktienkurs steigt also vielleicht müssen wir uns da wirklich nochmal was mit.
Wieso.
Gabs gab's auch schon fälle letztens wieder bei google bei der appstore geschichte also.
So nach dem motto weil's aus vom tisch ist weil sie alle gedacht habe ja auch mehr sein kann.
Das war diese die historisch höchste strafe fünf milliarden oder so ne und der aktienmarkt ich dachte schon wer was schlimmes.
Alles schon eingepreist.
Hör dann aber facebook weiter facebook weiter bemüht seinen irgendwie seinen ruf zu klären jetzt haben sie gesagt pass auf deutsche straff verkehr statt,
entschuldigung deutsche strafverfolgung nicht drauf verteidiger werden strafverfolgen.
Bullen werden in werden künftig.
Straff verkehrs kreuzung.
Werden künftig bei hasskriminalität kriminalität deutlich schneller auskunft bekommt denn,
bisher wenn du irgendwie dann auch irgendwie so ganz klar wenn du irgendwie als deutsche polizei ein auskunft versuchen zur hasskriminalität zum beispiel bei volksverhetzung an facebook gestellt hast ja,
dann musstest du wurdest du an das internationale rechts hilfe verfahren im land verwiesen.
Ja kenne ich gar nicht aber es offenbar ein internationales rechts hilfe verfahren,
natürlich hier dann eben das.
Quasi erschwert ja,
der sagt jetzt also facebook ja pass auf.
Wir machen das wenn wir erkennen das auch so an wenn ihr euch bei uns meldet so ihr habt jetzt also ihr kriegt jetzt hier eine kundennummer bei uns ne kriegt jetzt einen account ihr könnt also diese auskünfte im falle
der dann irgendwie,
schneller bekommen das klingt,
zunächst nach einer ganz guten nachricht andererseits natürlich auch zu einem nach,
so eine erleichterte auskunft möglichkeiten heißt im zweifelsfall halt inflationär gebrauch.
Von auskünfte und wir wissen wie kritisch da natürlich insbesondere das
netz dg gesehen wird aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe sagte die facebook sprecherin dass es sich erstmal nur auf volks freiheit seine inhalte hakenkreuz holocaust leugnen jungen und ähnliches
eindeutiges ja,
strafbares und nicht zu akzeptieren das material handelt aber es ist natürlich auch dass sich so etwas ausweitet also eine,
eine nachricht die erstmal mit zwiegespalten entgegengenommen werden muss und die auch natürlich hier in den kontext halle fällt.
Wo die sozialen netzwerke als echokammern des hasses immer wieder eine rolle spielen.
Was mich auf wundert ich dachte eigentlich dass das netz in deutschland ist schon dazu geführt hat dass große plattform betreiber eine ladung s fähige adresse in deutschland haben müssen und.
Ja ja aber da da gibt's ja in dem fall geht es bei dem netz dg geht's ja um im prinzip wäscherei hier geht es um auskunft ersuchen also quasi im prinzip der kontext dafür ist einmal,
klar halle und künast.
Dass das renate künast urteil dir im ausführlich beschimpft,
wurde und ein auskunft ersuchen an facebook gestellt hat und quasi gesagt ja ich will wissen wer diese menschen sind ich möchte dir jetzt möchte rechtlich gegen die vorgehen.
Und sie quasi diese auskunft gar nicht erst bekommen hat in diesem in diesem kontext sagt facebook jetzt also hier pass auf,
nicht wenn's um renate künast geht die wollen wir nach wie vor beschimpfen können wie wir wollen,
der hakenkreuz oder so denn dann sehen wir,
sehen wir uns bemühen sich den kürzeren dienstweg einzuschlagen.
Wir reden auch nochmal über ihre evidenz also in dem contest und das glaube ich auch diskutieren.
Steht übrigens für league und es sozusagen ein,
ja gegenseitiger rechts vertrag zwischen zwei oder mir ländern wo man halt anfragen auf rechts unterstützung stellen kann also halt so der offizielle prozess wie man sagt ja hier wir haben hier ein fall hilf mir.
Beim thema evidenz tatsächlich eine rolle spielen sollen wir das thema evidenz mal hierhin neben thomas.
Ja können wir machen also,
evidenz bezeichnet ein e-book gesetz die evidenz verordnung also es ist ein eingesetzt das duo machen will was in allen eu-ländern dann sofort anwendbar ist und da geht es genau um diese frage wie komme ich eigentlich an die daten von
internet unternehmen eigentlich muss man sich ja vorstellen du hast einen deutschen roster und stell dir vor die ungarische polizei hätte gerne
daten von kunden bei diesem roster im moment muss sie also die ungarische polizei,
über ein an die
deutsche polizei gehen und die würde dann wenn die straftat aufgrund der diese daten beschafft werden sollen auch eine straftat in deutschland ist,
weiter gehen und diese daten von dort holen und das ganze ist halt eben ein prozess der mehrere
beinhaltet und auch mal ein bisschen länger dauern kann das könnte man rechtsstaat nennen dass das irgendwie ordentlich geprüft wird,
jeder starter nochmal auch seine eigenen selbst cards hat ob in die privatsphäre von menschen eingegriffen werden soll in dieser stelle aber man kann das ganze natürlich auch als ein hemmnis für die strafverfolgung sehen und genau der logik,
folgt die eu-kommission leider als sie die vor ort,
auf den weg gebracht hat das ist ein gesetz an dem wir schon
recht lange arbeiten auch innerhalb von von idee.
Und dass wir sehr sehr kritisch sehen weil eigentlich müsste man nur dieser auf eine neue beine stellen und dort automatisieren aber,
dass ich sozusagen wirklich die komplett,
rechtsstaatlichen schranken eine staates komplett umgehen kann,
und im zweifelsfall die ungarische polizei durch die polnische irgendwo daten beschaffen kann ohne dass sie irgendjemand in dem land bescheid sagt das ist sehr kritisch zu sehen,
vor allem auch geht es hier ein dann wirklich nur noch darum ob die die firmen auch überhaupt eine möglichkeit haben,
sich zu beschweren dass die überhaupt auch mal sagen kann und gut ich glaub diese anfrage ist nicht berechtigt und ich will dass das jetzt mal richtig geprüft wird auch das sind punkte über die wir uns streiten bei dieser evidenz verordnung
das gesetz ist sowohl im parlament wie im rat noch nicht beschlossen.
Wir haben es geschafft dass zu verzögern weil auch es ist wirklich massive bauchschmerzen gibt auch zum teil bei,
den regierungen weil die natürlich auch ein bisschen um ihre eigene souveränität
fürchten wenn sozusagen von anderen staaten direkt auf die daten von ihrer bevölkerung zugegriffen werden kann.
Und ja es ist insgesamt ein sehr kritisches gesetz was aber leider uns noch eine zeit lang beschäftigen wird,
und ja das ganze ist auch gemeinsam mit dem us cloud,
also es würde jetzt hier ein bisschen zu weit führen aber das ganze ist in der ausbaustufe munkelt man zumindest auch nicht nur auf europa beschränkt sondern soll auch gerade bei dem transatlantischen daten austausch
eine wichtige rolle spielen.
Und sind wir es gut eigentlich nicht oder wenn.
Wollen wir nicht als
events verordnung unser unser ziel ist gerade die zu verhindern,
darum kämpfen wir und wie gesagt es sowohl im rat wie im parlament noch nicht gegessen im moment ist es nur ein vorschlag der eu-kommission
und man muss dann halt schauen inwieweit der jetzt sondern in der laufenden legislaturperiode die erst begonnen hat überhaupt noch zum abschluss findet aber es gibt auf jeden fall druck gerade wieder im im rat dass das durch geboxt wird aber
genauso haben wir auch kritische stimmen sowohl im parlament wie im rat.
Tja was haben wir denn sonst neues wir haben lange nicht mehr über ibiza gesprochen.
Aux
Okay den kann ich nicht okay alle gute nachricht aus österreich aber ich wollte euch irgendwie ein update geben.
Also in österreich ist viel passiert zweitausendneunzehn im grunde alles,
ganz so kurz vor der europawahl im mai als das ibiza video veröffentlicht wurde durch süddeutsche zeitung und spiegel
und dieses dieses video das zwar führende,
politiker youngo dinos und ein christian strache in einer wieder in ibiza zeigt wie sie die kronen juwelen der republik,
verscherbeln an eine angebliche russische oligarchen hat zu
den rücktritt dieser beiden politiker geführt am auch den rücktritt von hans christian strache als vizekanzler und dann in weiterer folge zu
dem kompletten zusammenbrechen der türkisblau also der rechtsextremen bundesregierung in österreich,
diese regierung wurde dann eben durch eine misstrauen sabbeln trag abgewählt.
Das war sozusagen schon die zweite regierung die sebastian kurz gesprengt hat weil er sich damals verkalkung viert hat im mai es ist immer,
zeichnet also der junge härte so altes wie ich hat es innerhalb von zwei jahren geschafft zwei regierungen zu sprengen und voller zweiunddreißig jahre alt ist
die zweiunddreißigjährige regierungsbeteiligung seiner partei der övp zu beenden.
Ja wieviel regierung hast du denn auf dem carport schon thomas.
Das überlassen wir anna.
Genau das sollen die biographie machen auf jeden fall hat,
das ganze dazu geführt dass die fpö mal in den europawahlen schon,
stürzt ist auf ungefähr achtzehn prozent wenn ich mich richtig erinnere und
ja die ganze sache ist dann über den sommer weiter gefeiert worden also man hat dieses länger boys lied going to its a sehr sehr oft hingehört.
Bei lok bundespolitik.
Genau und die liebe boy sind auch einmal nach dem gekommen und haben ein gratis konzert am helden platz gegeben.
Sehr schön
und ja also aber politisch haben wir im moment ein kerth government unser grüner bundespräsident alexander van der bellen hat
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der republik,
eine frau mit der regierungsbildung beauftragt beginnt der bioladen ehemalige,
präsidentin des verfassungsgerichtshofs ist unsere derzeitige bundeskanzlerin.
War doch dieser schöne slogan bierlaune statt koks ne.
Das ist gut also die diese regierung ist auch.
Vergleichsweise unproblematisch also die müht sich ähm eigentlich nur die geschäfte weiterzuführen
und wobei wir haben auch schon bei dieser regierung jetzt ein gesetz sehr sehr scharf kritisieren müssen weil das videoüberwachung in gefängnissen erlaubt und handys in gefängnissen verbietet und sogar auch irgendwie nach träume
wieder überwachen lassen will also aber ein gesetz in,
drei vier monaten regierung ist echt ein guter schnitt also da haben wir normalerweise mehr zu tun
und diese kärtchen regierung wird uns auch noch eine zeit lang bleiben es ist nämlich so dass,
am ende september in österreich gewählt wurde wir hatten wieder in der nationalratswahl weil einfach klar aber so wie es vorher war diese mehrheitsverhältnisse funktioniert nicht wir müssen jetzt einfach auch wirklich neuwahlen machen.
Und ein paar wochen zwei wochen vor diesem neuwahlen haben sich die macher von ibiza nochmal,
gemeldet und es wurden sachverhalte öffentlich in einer anzeige die jetzt auch ein bissel den hintergrund dieses videos beleuchten und scheinbar war es so dass dieses video was dein epizentrum gedreht wurde
eigentlich nur dass das das nachgestellt hat was an
korruption verhältnissen rund um ein christian strache sowieso schon den machen von ibiza bekannt.
Also laut dieser anzeige gab es da einen leibwächter von heinz christian strache der scheinbar eine,
angefangen hat gegen seinen ehemaligen chef material zu sammeln und dieses material auch anderen leuten zur verfügung gestellt hat
und die sind zuerst auf die idee gekommen dieses material belegt scheinbar irgendwie größere mengen an bargeld die aus osteuropäischen kreisen kommen und die dazu geführt haben dass
es da auch sehr einen luxuriösen lebensstil gab,
da wieder später von der partei auch zugegeben wurde zehntausend euro spießen konto im monat und zweitausendfünfhundert euro miete zuschuss für herrn strache und das das hat
ihnen dann wirklich nochmal das genick gebrochen also strache hatte ein paar wochen vor dem bekannt werden dieser anzeige sogar noch irgendwie seinen rücktritt,
als einen seine rückkehr angekündigt sozusagen einem coming back in guter österreichischer mania
und daraus wurde jetzt nichts inzwischen ist er aus der partei ausgeschlossen und da,
definitiv ist es eher so schaut so aus das heißt christian strahlen seine eigene partei gegründet bei der wiederwahl und der fpö konkurrenz macht,
was das rechte lager und die rechte stimme natürlich bitten würde und nicht die schlechteste variante.
Ja genau also das ist in österreich auch immer das ding empfehle ich euch in deutschland bei der afd das einzige was euch langfristig hilft es wenn diese parteien sich gegenseitig spalten.
Vor noch eine partei.
Ja was macht eigentlich hier wieso weil die andere braut ja die hat das auch probiert es hat nicht funktioniert.
Petry die blauen ja bis heute spitzen noch eine wenn wir genug finden die.
Ja da ist noch viel platz am stimmzettel.
Genau wir brauchen einfach noch viel mehr nazi partei.
Was was auf jeden fall dann auch in allen analysen von kommentatoren diese wahl die eine heilige meinung war ist dass du,
diese speisen affäre rund um heinz christian strache die fpö nochmal einen massiven dämpfer,
bekommen hat also sie war vor dieser speisen affäre schon ungefähr wieder bei zwanzig zweiundzwanzig prozent in den umfragen und hat es dann durch diese affäre,
aber nur noch auf sechzehn prozent zirka geschafft und das war einfach.
Unter der schmerzfrei also über die schmerzgrenze für die partei dann sozusagen einen einen auftrag abzuleiten in die opposition zu gehen und nicht einer nochmals zeigen regierung,
zur verfügung zu stehen und auch die övp die sehr gut abgeschnitten hat mit siebenunddreißig prozent ist es natürlich nochmal schwieriger jetzt argumentieren wieso man
nochmal mit einer partei zusammengeht die so massiv verloren hat
seit der letzten wahl minus zehn prozent zirka und wieso man dann auch mit einer partei nochmal in regierung geht die offensichtlich solche korruption probleme hat
und da reden wir ja noch gar nicht von dem ganzen einzelfällen,
an narzisstischen äußerungen und,
den ganzen,
sonst noch bei der fpö zu kritisieren wäre auch an,
all das führt uns dahin dass österreich heute eben ein weiter noch eine
weil wir im moment sondierungsgespräche zumindest mal laufen zwischen der övp und den grünen also wir könnten.
Eine schwarz grüne bundesregierung bekommen was ein sehr spannendes experiment ist auf bundesebene hatten wir das noch nie da,
das sicherlich sehr viele probleme noch aus zu schmerzen und es geht auch darum ob man das inhaltlich zusammenbringt weil einiges muss ich eigentlich nur so in dem thema klima und da auch nur auf der rhetorischen ebene,
sich diese zwei parteien in wirtschaftspolitischen sozialpolitischen angelegenheiten
einig werden das ist noch ganz offen und gerade in dem thema migration,
politik glaube ich wird es äußerst schwierig das auf einen nenner zu bringen,
aber das ist im moment zumindest kombination in der sondiert und hoffentlich auch bald koalitions verhandelt,
und ja insofern bleibt das auf jeden fall spannend,
es gab dann irgendwie noch mehr kuriositäten über die facebook-seite von hans christian strache die jetzt noch deaktiviert ist aber,
das ist auch wirklich ein kurios und wir haben hier schon zu viel über facebook geredet in dieser sendung was man einfach abschließend sagen kann ist der schöne ibiza sommer in österreich,
der uns aus.
Weiter.
Der ja das wetter ist auch immer noch schön da aber wir wir wir haben's halt es fühlt sich so an.
Wir haben den aus der faschismus gerade mal noch so,
noch noch weggedrückt bekommen ja also da ist eine regierung die wahrscheinlich auf eine dekade ausgelegt war von herrn kurz mit herrn strache.
Die würde es zumindest bis auf weiteres nicht geben und stattdessen haben wir schwarz grün grün
und das ist schon eine enorme verbesserung würde ich mein und das heißt auch dass wir auch immer getan hat der republik einen großen dienst erbracht hat,
und ja,
der genau das war es so halb bekannter gibt es genügend artikel inzwischen auch wenn keiner von dem bisher vor die kamera getreten ist und erklärt hat wieso oder warum aber ja
ist auf jeden fall so dass ja gerade interessante zeiten in österreich passieren.
Ja leute das sind unsere guten nachrichten nazis nur achtzehn prozent der stimmen bekommen oder wann sechzehn sechzehn so darüber kann man sich heutzutage schon freuen ist doch äh toll.
Wer in thüringen wohnt und sich wegen der wahlergebnisse sorgen macht kann besser nach österreich auswandern.
Da ist noch sechs prozent weniger.
Ja aber bleiben wir in österreich ein anderes thema das wir im podcast schonmal besprochen haben ist der algorithmus ein.
Das war diese geschichte mit wie.
Service und arbeitslosen.
Bewertet wird wofür man denn so geeignet ist.
Genau also in deutschland würde man jobcenter sagen und das hat ein computerprogramm entscheidet ob du als arbeitssuchende person noch eine schulung bekommst oder förderungen bekommst
das kann man sehr kritisch sehen vor allem in dem beispiel in österreich wir haben dieses thema schon mal in der folge zweihundert
die verfassungsklage thematisiert als,
in wien bei der private aufgezeichnet haben
und wer sich daran nicht erinnert also dass das ems des arbeitsmarktservice hat eben im november zweitausendachtzehn schon angekündigt dass sie ein ein computerprogramm zum einsatz bringen wollen das arbeitssuchende eben drei kategorien unterteilt.
Hohen mittleren und niedrigen job chancen und je nachdem wie du da kategorisiert wirst trägst du halt noch eine schulung gezahlt oder eben nicht
und dieses computerprogramm ist noch nicht autonomes ist nur eine entscheidungshilfe für die
menschlichen äh beraterinnen beim ems die
eine einordnung der leute machen und gleichzeitig ist es aber so dass mit zeichen automatisierten entscheidungshilfe ein enormer druck aufgebaut wird wenn du dich dann entgegen dem computerprogramm entscheidest brauchst du
schon wirklich einen guten grunde muss dir sehr sicher sein also der rechtfertigung druck ist beides höher wenn du nicht der,
automatisierten empfehlung folgst und diese automatisierten empfehlungen sind im fall des m s algorithmus eben hochgradig diskriminierend also es gibt da,
natürlich dass das modell offen ist kann man das klar sagen einfach gewisse
benachteiligungen wenn du eine frau bist kriegst du schon mal sowieso null komma vierzehn punkte abzug wenn du auch noch betreuungsmöglichkeiten hast und eine frau bist nochmal
null komma fünfzehn prozent aber das ist eben geschlechts
abhängig auch das alte spielt eine rolle also wenn du über dreißig bist hast du schon mal einen abzug und wenn du über fünfzig
nochmal ein viel höheren abzug gesundheitliche beeinträchtigungen werden die negativ ausgelegt von diesem system.
Insgesamt ist das ding halt
hardcore diskriminierend es wird
so gerechtfertigt dass diese diskriminierung nur der skeptik sind dass der arbeitsmarkt selbst nach geschlecht nach betreuung und nach alter diskriminieren würde und das system nur versucht das abzubilden aber,
man könnte eben halt auch sagen dass diese bestehenden vorteile zementiert werden durch solche algorithmen,
die automatisierten menschen in gruppen zuordnen das thema haben wir jetzt eben schon seit bald einem jahr in österreich thematisiert.
Und es hat sich aber nicht wirklich viel getan also dass das album eine strategie fährt wo sie versuchen die leiter zu unterteilen und die härtesten kritiker rennen
in eine ein forschungsprojekt gesteckt haben und gleich mal mit einem mdr mundtot gemacht haben.
Was ich sehr sehr kritisch finde,
ich war noch nie so ein unterzeichnen und wenn dann würde ich so verbrechen aber wir haben dann im rahmen unserer möglichkeiten als effizienter works das thema mal
bei dem special roberto stream filip außen eingeworfen weil wir mit dem workshop hatten im februar
der das auch so in seinem letzten bericht über algorithmen in sozialhilfe systemen hat extra österreich extra nochmal als
negativbeispiel angeführt hat und ja insgesamt
gibt es jetzt auch noch etwas dass man tun kann wenn man,
in österreich in den letzten jahren schon mal arbeitssuchend war
kann man ein auskunft ersuchen an das einem es stellen,
wir haben uns gedacht das wäre doch eigentlich ganz spannend wenn du es jetzt schon,
seit dem jahr diesen algorithmus zum einsatz bringt müssen sehr massive daten auch über die leute
vorliegen haben die sind dann ja der input für diese automatisierte berechnung.
Und äh deswegen haben wir formulare für auskunft versuchen auf unserer website gepackt die wir hier auch verlinken,
und das war ganz lustig als wir mit diesem blogpost online gingen war hat keine dreißig minuten
dauert bis das ems bei uns angerufen hat und gesagt hat an diesem bock post gesehen könnt ihr den,
wieder runternehmen wir haben da nämlich keinen prozess für datenschutz auskünfte und die leute
da so bis zu hundertvierzig seiten und das muss man teils manuell zusammensammeln ein.
Da hätten sie das doch mal als erstes automatisieren können bevor sie ihre eigene arbeit automatisieren.
Wenn man sich denken müssen hätten sie auch rechtlich tun müssen wenn sie die datenschutzgrundverordnung ernst nehme.
Es ist immer unklug unklug bei ausrede datenschutz aktivisten anzurufen und ehrlich zu sein.
Ja du ich hab wenig mitleid mit leuten die gerade marginalisiert gruppen in der gesellschaft mit solchen systemen versuchen
a recht unmenschliche anzutun und ich glaube dass das wenigste was man leiten die so massiv,
daten sammeln und missbrauchen antun kann ist dass sie das recht aus auskunft über diese daten den menschen auch zur verfügung stellen und damit müssen die umgehen und wir werden auch noch weiter bei der sache dran bleiben aber das ist so etwas konkretes was man machen kann wer
eine auskunft stellt und antwort bekommt kann sich auch gerne bei uns melden,
weil wir natürlich jetzt auch versuchen werden diesen algorithmus zu revers ingenieuren weil im moment ist nur,
ein teil davon öffentlich bekannt es gibt auch langfristige berechnungen modelle die wir jetzt gerade um auch unter die lupe nehmen,
um einfach noch mehr herauszufinden wie das denn wirklich funktioniert und ja vielleicht auch noch mehr aktionen dazu machen werden in der zukunft.
Ich also die.
Wenn das da wenigstens automatisiert wird ja wenn dieser algorithmus öffentlich ist damit nicht ein größeres ausmaß an transparenz.
Hergestellt über diskriminierung.
Sonst war und wäre es nicht sogar unter umständen so dass wenn wir hier so etwas haben wir.
Ein vier punkte abzug für geschlecht das hier quasi die die diskriminierung
nachweisbar in code gegossen ist und somit auch sehr viel einfacher weg zu klagen ist also wenn du eigenverantwortlich diskriminierende arbeit arbeiter arbeitsverbot drinnen hättest dann wirst du irgendwie nie,
gibt's erfolgreich
gegen so etwas wie ein gen dabei ist oder eine benachteiligung von hautfarben schattierungen,
vorgehen können wenn das aber in code gegossen ist hast du irgendwie was relativ fundamentales wurde sofort sein kannst das,
klagen weg und insofern frag ich mich bei dieser sache die ganze zeit ob das wirklich etwas ist vor gegen man kämpfen will ob das jetzt emanzipatorischen,
zielführend ist oder wenn man sagt okay alles klar lass uns das mit einem
neutralen algorithmus tun und dann lass uns den transparent bekommt lass uns den grün und blau klagen bis der gerecht ist und dann lass uns jeden lass uns
diesen algorithmus auf eine weise verpflichtend machen.
Ja also das ist auch das sind ein paar grundlegende fragen klar es gibt hier eine klage möglichkeit und ich warte auch schon seit dem jahr dass die gleichbehandlung sanwald schafft in österreich da mit einer klare endlich tätig wird weil die hätten rechtlich das ganz einfach in ihrem
dahinter stellt sich so eine philosophische frage ist es,
wenn du von einem algorithmus diskriminiert wirst oder von einem menschen.
Ne meine meine meine argumentation wäre wenn du von einem algorithmus diskriminiert wirst kannst du dich wenigstens dagegen wehren.
Ja und vor allem in dem fall wo es kein
irgendwie maschinen algorithmus ist sondern die diskriminierung schon ganz klar in den grundlegenden modell festgeschrieben ist ja wenn frau dann minus null komma vierzehn prozent punkte
das das das ist insofern dann einfacher da auch klarer zu zeigen was sache ist
ähm aber ja also man hat hier natürlich auch tags weglaufen das müsste man sich dann eben nach konkret antidiskriminierung recht anschauen
und das sind viele leute in österreich dabei das zu tun aber
ich greif das hier auch auf weil uns geht 's jetzt mal überhaupt darum diese transparenz herzustellen weil die
der muster jetzt bekannt ist eben nur eines von mehreren berechnungen modellen etwas zum einsatz kommt wir haben informationsfreiheit anfragen geschickt wo dann irgendwie zurückkam ja also diese andere algorithmus die könnten wir ihn schon geben aber das würde viertausendfünfhundert euro kosten
woher und schon überlegt haben crowdfunding zu machen dafür
aber ja es ist ein laufenden prozess wo man sich auch über darüber informieren kann auf unserer webseite und in den medien in österreich wieder future.
Ja future ist genau der richtige punkt in deutschland deutschland hatte jetzt auch so eine temporäre futurezone digitalgipfel.
War wahnsinns wahnsinns ding fünfzig jahre internet deutschland lädt zum digitalgipfel.
Man darf darüber keine witze machen aber.
Sicher in deutschland ja eher dann fünf.
Ja in deutschland erstes und peter altmaier gestürzt äh ist wurde gestürzt bei diesem digitalgipfel das ist natürlich eine headline die man sich nicht entgehen lassen kann.
Ja
Von sich selbst.
Genau er wurde von sich selber gestürzt der ist relativ ungünstig da von der bühne gefallen und er wurde dann abgeschirmt kurz bewusstlos und ja,
das war so der höhepunkt des digital gipfels ansonsten.
Wurde dort garcia x vorgestellt.
Die deutsche cloud die euro cloud.
Niemand geringeres als die personifizierte erde die uhr mutter von alex.
Die nimmt alles auf.
Dürfte als namensgeber drin,
dürfte als namensgeber herhalten ich sehe also kurz tim hatte offenbar probleme mit seinem adblocker bist du noch nicht von safari weg migriert das ist sowieso.
Grauenhaft.
Auf dieses internet ja ok.
Person muss ich auch mal überlegen mit wem sie irgendwie werbung schalten.
Ja du kriegst komische werbung impfen ist quatsch wird die aok auf der future so.
Daneben so ein leicht begleitetes ukrainische des.
Klicke mal drauf das ist das hin.
Trainer der kommt jetzt hier wieder netz politik die teddys beim finale.
So die uhr mutter der erde die personifizierte erde darf erhalten für die deutsche cloud,
ja und zwar x y wird mit offenen technologien
und offenen schnittstellen für daten austausch und daten migration frei wählbar standorten für cloud angebote.
Nun google amazon und microsoft mit ihren cloud den kampf ansagen insofern eminent and,
auf der cloud predigten sie müssen sich einen transfer regeln und standards halten das problem an x ist es scheint noch keine einzelne zeile code zu geben das ist jetzt nur so eine interessent begründung wir werden sehen ob das irgendwie,
der neue heiße scheiß wird oder nicht.
Ist der westen euro cloud.
Euro ihr genau euro klaut nee entschuldigung ich hab das erstmal deutschlandweit gesehen ist euro dänemark thema.
Das heißt die wolke.
X ja besser besser spät als.
Mal schauen ob das nicht vielleicht dann doch leider ein nie wird also es ist eine eine absicht begründung ehrlich übrigens wie der digitalpakt das ist auch wieder meine güte der digitalpakt kommt wir werden.
Mitte zwanzig zwanzig wird der digitalpakt vorgestellt,
und das ist so ein klassisches also ich werd mich da melden aber es ist ein klassisches ding,
sitze die machen auch gar keinen hehl daraus die sagen also wir haben die
in einem ersten schritt werden alle wesentlichen akteure
und ihre beiträge im bereich der cybersicherheit auf der basis einer internet basierten erhebung erfasst zu deutsch,
wer beim digitalpakt dabei sein will kann sich anmelden.
Kommt in excel tabelle.
Ein formular im.
Die kommt dann der excel-tabelle.
Kommt in geyer x box das ist ein geiler dogs dann und in einem zweiten schritt.
Wird die quadriceps mit den identifizierten identifizierten herausragenden akteuren der cyber-sicherheit landschaft deutschlands.
Herausragenden akteure deshalb er sich jetzt landschaft deutschland werden eine gesamtgesellschaftliche erklärung zu silber sicherheit erarbeiten und vorstellen.
Eine quadrieren.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau was ist das ich habe das jetzt.
Ein vier ständiger wagen ist das was oben auf dem brandenburger tor drauf steht.
Natürlich gar ja und verträge also es ist jetzt die ganz große nummer.
Ja die besten die top voll hätte man früher gesagt ne die top vor.
So also man kann sich da melden dann wird man eine gesamt gesellschaftliche erklärung zu silber sicherheit erarbeiten und vorstellen.
Deutschland sucht den cyber star.
Genau das werden die vorstellen zeitfenster mitte zwanzig zwanzig ja also mitte zwanzig zwanzig wird etwas vorgestellt was noch zu erarbeiten ist von leuten die sich jetzt grade im internet anmelden dürfen ja.
Und dann dritter schritt wo habe ich es gerade hier.
Dritter schritt im dritten schritt soll das ergebnis der erhebung,
einer wissenschaftlichen wirkungslos messung unterzogen werden,
weiterführende handlungsempfehlung insbesondere für die nächste legislaturperiode zu generieren.
Legislaturperiode ihr periode geht maximal noch bis zwanzig einundzwanzig wenn ich das richtig.
Ich habe endlich bei evidenz basierte politik was willst du mehr.
Ja jetzt kommt mein punkt.
Wenn die jetzt sagen du kannst dich anmelden wir werden dann jemanden auswählen dann wird etwas formuliert ist mitte zwanzig zwanzig fertig und das heißt digitalpakt ja.
Da habe ich einen blöd bösen verdacht dass da schon jemand mal einen entwurf geschrieben hat.
Ja wäre nicht das erste mal dass das auf diese weise läuft ja also wenn ihr jetzt schon wissen am ende kommt ein digitalpakt raus und zwar mitte zwanzig zwanzig man kann sich heute melden da werden dann wahrscheinlich nochmal bei sowas wenn dann üblicherweise vielleicht mal,
zwei drei treffen gemacht wo dann geguckt wird welche,
der eingeladen stakeholder denn mit an bord bleiben und ihren guten namen dafür hergeben,
ich werde mir es ist ja auch in ordnung das so zu machen ja ich werde mich da ja auch mal anmelden als herausragende aktuell der selber sicherheitslage landschaft in deutsch.
Cyber star.
Servus da ja ob ich da wirklich chancen hab unter dieter bohlen dann.
Ich sehe schon auf die bühne zum wohl im geräuschen gleisen da gleisen des flutlicht konfetti regen linos.
Ich frag mich halt ernsthaft was das noch irgendwie eine gesamtgesellschaftliche erklärung zur cybersicherheit was.
Was will was brauchen wir jetzt nochmal für so einen akt von handeln die sich da hinstellen.
Verena wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt gründe einen arbeitskreis und das ist genau das was hier wieder stattfindet,
ich meine ich bin ich beobachte ja alles wohlwollend bitte bitte macht das ist super es wird ganz toll.
Ich bin mal gespannt wie viel wirksamkeit mit wieviel wirksamkeit erwartung wieder in sowas reingehen können ich bin ja technische richtige router geschädigte da wurden wir ja schon mal zwei jahre durchgebürstet wo am ende.
Nichts von übrig blieb was nochmal irgendwo in vertretbar war oder,
in die in die welt gekommen wäre in messbaren
werden ich bin gespannt wie das da ist ja vor allem stelle ich mir so eine gesamtgesellschaftliche erklärung bei den zahlen vor ja das hat irgendwie john perry ballon,
vor wie viel jahren.
Als er das sind da wo es vorgestellt hat eine gesamtgesellschaftliche erklärung zum cyber jetzt ist das halber sicherheit sein ich bin sehr gespannt
ich hoffe ich meine das beste was da zu erhoffen wäre wäre natürlich ein klares bekenntnis zu einer strikt defensiven ausrichtung da gibt's überall hoffnung wir werden uns dafür
bemühen und einsetzen aber können auf wiedersehen,
nur hoffen dass da am ende keiner von der von der bühne fällt.
Sonderpreis geht nochmal an thorsten kleinste in seinem artikel über schön begriff die daten souveräne wollen ich klaut hervorgerufen hat und.
Ich sage mal was wo meine erwartung ist was für diese x klaut betrifft.
Peter oder.
Ja also selbst wenn und das würde ich schon bezweifeln dass auch wirklich mal existiert ja.
Willst du markt einfach flocken weil's einfach zu teuer engineer hat und nicht irgendwie aus so einem soliden privatwirtschaftlichen
prozess heraus entstanden ist und einfach zu teuer ist am ende werden amazon und microsoft et cetera dafür sorgen dass ihre cloud einfach da die features haben die paar check box ist dieses jahr jetzt angeklickt haben wollen das haben sie dann
was mein preis an und fertig.
Es ist nicht der erste versuch eines wirtschaftsministers deutsche cloud infrastrukturen zu.
Ich sag nur europäische suchmaschine.
Der europäische suchmaschine wir haben auch sonst irgendwelche btc zertifizierung für klaus und hast du alles nicht gesehen alles wirtschaftsförderung s maßnahmen wie auch diese.
Genau wird einfach ein bisschen geld verteilt und da kann man sich da beantragen also.
Und dann sitzen die deutschen anbieter da und sagen wir müssen irgendwas wir müssen irgendwie sicherheit oder datenschutz zu definieren das
dass google und amazon da nicht reinkommen und wir müssen es am besten so definieren dass wir die als unsicher in irgendeiner weise brandmarken können und ein vermeintlich.
Objektiven branchen standard haben den die nicht erfüllen können.
Ehrlich wie sie ja gerade übrigens bemüht sind das immer noch mit zu machen ja wo es muss ihn ja auch nicht gelingt wenn du eben fünfzig jahre sechzig siebzig jahre durchs land gehst.
Und den entfesselten liberalen kapitalismus predigt
dann wird es halt irgendwann schwierig wenn du feststellst dass andere günstigere bessere angebote machen mit denen du nicht konkurrieren kannst und du plötzlich in protektionismus verfallen möchtest da hast du halt auf einmal schwierigkeiten so ist der kapitalismus der fickt immer in beide richtungen.
So und das.
Das ist halt schwierig wenn du dran bist.
Wird schwierig heute mit der titel wahl.
Ihr habt schon aufgeschrieben.
Die liste ist so lange.
Nächstes thema.
Ah sehr schön.
Ja russland russland kennst du noch.
Land russland.
Noch kennst du noch deutschland routinen das war ja meine güte was waren wir stolz.
Nach ähm nach schlank nett und so ne nach norden kam es ja dann so was das internet
ist äh international das kann aber gar nicht sein wir wollen eine wir wollen im prinzip eine deutsche sichere infrastruktur haben wir wollen
e-mail made in germany ne wir schreiben jetzt irgendwie unsere routinen protokolle um und sorgen dafür dass,
unsere e-mails nur noch im inland inländischen versand werden
haben sorge dass irgendwie vor high king und so weiter da wurde das will ich nur freundlich in erinnerung rufen sie,
positiv diskutiert zu sagen wir machen ein deutschland ja.
Deutschland.
Ist das doch ich glaub schon oder ich werd jetzt ausgedacht.
Ich falls essen.
Weißt du es dir jetzt ausgedacht hast ist es in der welt und es wird.
Deutschland alles gut ich hätte lieber deutsch waren aber.
Es gibt 's ab erstmal deutschland und dann können wir gucken also man wollte ein deutschland haben.
Deutsche wähler.
Und dann.
Also für die für die neu dazugekommen laden steht für locker dass deutschland wollte man haben so jetzt russland hat sich gesagt geile idee machen wir auch.
Und hat jetzt glaube ich heute
das gesetz auch tatsächlich verabschiedet locker und jetzt grade schon von ersten plänen damals berichtet sagen jetzt im prinzip wir wollen eigene infrastruktur für ein souveränes netz um mit diesem souveränen netz mögliches halber angriff aus dem ausland zu verhindern,
quasi sie wollen in der lage sein sich vom,
internet zu isolieren ohne dass ihnen was zusammen klappt.
So argumentieren sie und das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant weil es wird dir würde dir in deutschland tatsächlich ohne weiteres nicht gelingen würde,
was jetzt hoffentlich nicht passiert aber stellen wir uns vor an den landesgrenzen deutschlands würden alle verbindungen in anderen netze,
getrennt.
Dann trete eine situation ein dass wir eben 'ne ganze reihe internetverbindungen einerseits
in das ausland und durch das ausland nicht mehr herstellen könnten und,
im zweifelsfall aber auch eine reihe innerdeutsche verbindung nicht mehr sinnvoll herstellen könnt oder neu konfigurieren müssten und.
Außerdem haben wir im zweifelsfall eine ganze reihe an abhängigkeiten auf,
sagen wir mal services oder so die sich nicht in deutschland befinden sein dass irgendwelche pdf server irgendwelche d server oder irgendwelche cloud und hast du alles nicht gesehen was dann ausfallen würde.
Russland sagt also jetzt das wollen wir gerne tun und,
begründet das eben mit fragen der sicherheit leider hat das aber natürlich sehr entscheidende folgen für zensur,
und überwachung denn wenn du ein russland hast,
dann hast du natürlich auch die vollständige überwachung.
Des datenverkehr und die vollständigen zensur möglichkeiten ehrlich wie china das hat deswegen
richtet sich dagegen natürlich auch naja breit ist protest in russland nie die wissen alle was das für den rest ihres lebens bedeutet sich an einem protest zu beteiligen aber
dann doch sehr karla widerstand der ihm sagt wir wollen hier,
dieses internet behalten wir möchten die internationale vernetzung weiter feiern und,
scheint uns etwas zu passieren was letztendlich das land in eine weitere isolation treiben wird wie es eben streckenweise in china schon der fall ist,
die russische regierung sagt quatsch wir wollen russland nicht vom web abkoppeln wir haben viel mehr die gefahr dass der,
russland vom netz abgeklemmt und deswegen braucht müssen wir auf eine unabhängige digitale infrastruktur hinarbeiten.
Tja diese infrastruktur perspektive wenn man nur rein technisch darauf,
würde ich halt schon bei dem argument bleiben dass es erstaunlich ist wenn,
wenn wir das in,
in deutschland feiern und in china und in russland ankreiden solche pläne stellt sich am natürlich gleichzeitig die frage russland wieder im zweifelsfall nichts gutes im schilde führen ja was solche maßnahmen.
Angeht das ist heute das thema ich hab da schon sehr viele anrufe zu auf der mailbox aber ich mache jetzt hier,
logbuch netz politik ich denke.
Russland ist mit so einer mit so einem vorstoß nicht zu trauen,
deutschland wäre genauso wenig zu trauen und diese frage der souveränität die spielt aber tatsächlich eine rolle denn wenn du den land wie china anschaust mit allen nachteilen die der irgendwie sich,
für demokratie meinungsfreiheit und,
bürgerlichen freiheiten und menschenrechte geschaffen haben durch ihre isolation so ist es den wenigstens gelungen.
Den punkt muss ja wenigstens mal machen sich von der von den wirtschaftlichen einfluss name versuchen zum beispiel,
der us internet giganten,
relativ getrennt und autonom zu halten das ist nicht der grund warum sie das getan haben aber sowas wie eine geile x kriegst du halt leichter etabliert wenn deine.
Bürgerinnen und bürger gar nicht die chance haben die produkte des imperialistischen klassen feindes,
über dieses internet zu erreichen ich finde es ein schwieriges thema es steht eher gegen,
ja gegen generell internationale politische überzeugung.
Ich weiß die idee dass das internet uns alle einander näher bringt ist ein bisschen in die jahre gekommen und dabei nicht besonders gut gealtert aber hier so ein vorstoß der balkan vierundhalb.
Sicherlich eines landes dass es hier nicht unbedingt zum schutz der eigenen infrastrukturen tut oder nicht nur zum schutz der eigenen infrastrukturen tut es vermutlich einfach ein schritt in die in eine richtung die,
zielführend ist.
Kommt von den hängt von den zielen ab diese natürlich zweifelhaft.
Tja wir nicht zu ein.
Ja finde ich auch ein schwieriges thema ich meine ähm,
das ist leider sind wir da eine literatur realisierung des internets an vielen stellen ist klar ich mein es ist ein macht faktor
und ich glaube dass russland hier vor allem auch dass das was machtpolitischen gründen tut bei kinder was immer auch wirtschaftspolitisch,
das das sehe ich in in in russland noch nicht so stark aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht der experte für russische digitalwirtschaft.
Ja also ein es ist eine es ist 'ne abweichung von dem wie menschen das internet
gebaut haben und sich gedacht haben als es noch nicht so enorm
den interessen der der märkte und anbieter unterworfen wurde ja wie du schon sagst es anging eingangs tim viele
realitäten im netz wurden geschaffen bevor irgendjemand auf die idee kommen zu sagen alter was macht ihr denn da internationales netzwerk wohl nicht so da müssen wir mal gucken da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie eine regel machen so und
da war eben schon auf eine zusammenarbeit der verfolgt der völkerverständigung und des friedens irgendwie die.
Kam wir kurz nochmal irgendwie heraus streichen das putin das wiederum eben zum fünfzigsten jahrestag des internets macht also das ist schon auch gut getan.
Es ist gut was macht währenddessen die eu thomas die interessiert dich doch.
Ach ja da bin ich ein großer fan davon ich
auch das ist irgendwie passend zum ersten november indem wir heute diesen podcast aufnehmen weil heute ist der tag wo eigentlich die,
neue kommission von ursula von der leyen ins amt hätte treten sollen und wie ihr euch vielleicht auch.
Die warten noch auf den brexit.
Genau es ist nicht nur brexit hätte vorbei sein sollen oder passiert sein sollen und die neue kommission im amt sein sollen beides passiert in
und das weil drei kommissionen kandidatinnen abgelehnt wurden vom europaparlament in ihren hering nämlich ähm,
die kommissar kandidatinnen von frankreich ungarn und rumänien vor allem die französische kandidat,
ist interessant sylvie hätte nämlich das digital resort dj connect übernehmen sollen und sie hat es eben nicht geschafft wie ihre zwei kollegen
auch vom
europaparlament eine mehrheit zu bekommen bei diesen hier rings muss nämlich dann auch nochmal immer dieses jeweilige person bestätigt werden und bei cola war es eben vor allem korruption skandale glaube ich und aber auch insgesamt eine sehr kritische betrachtung
von ihrer zeit als verteidigungsministerin in frankreich
das hat macron auch dem parlament und ursula von alleine,
an
Moment war es nicht so dass vor allem deshalb angepisst war weil er im prinzip rosa von allein vier mögliche kandidaten genannt hat und sie,
diese figur aus diesen vier ausgewählt hat die da nicht durchkam obwohl er schon darauf hingewiesen hat dass es unter umständen schwierig sein könnte.
Das weiß ich gar nicht ob er da.
So hab ich das nämlich raus gelesen.
Das das kann sein also ich meine wenn die anderen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht dass er sauer ist auf das parlament das ist die dass sie ab gewählt haben sondern auf die wahl von laien und die falsche einschätzung dass das wohl schon durchkommen würde.
Vielleicht war er auch also von alleine hat auch besonderen wert draufgelegt balance hinzubekommen in der kommission vielleicht war.
Ja das macht natürlich ein faktor gewesen sein aber trotzdem ist er so.
Ja ja gut dass macron sauer ist finde ich kann er ruhig gerade erst netz politischer perspektive gibt es äußerst viel zu kritisieren an herrn macron,
und der französische einfluss ist gerade auch mit dem blick auf das ausscheiden der briten durchaus etwas das vielen leuten kopfzerbrechen bereitet,
frankreich nicht nur im urheberrecht eine nicht sonderlich bürgerrecht freundliche position vertritt,
ja auf jeden fall gibt's schon mal neue,
von frankreich und aus ungarn rumänien lässt sich noch bitten jemanden zu nominieren,
und.
Wir haben noch keinen gefunden der nicht korrupt.
Ja ich glaube dass das auch wieder mit leckeren wein dort etwas zu tun hat,
es ist auf jeden fall der amtsantritt der kommission von der leyen auf zwanzig zwanzig verschoben worden also man redet irgendwie von ersten jänner also im moment gibt's gerade so ein wettrennen ob.
Was er erst kommt willst mein tipp haben.
Ich ich glaube das war das schon irgendwie ganz schnell dann hat die zwanzig über die bühne bringen muss weil ähnlich wie in österreich die regierung bioland ist auch die das komissariat die regierung juncker jetzt nur noch im
modus und hat halt einfach
kein politisches peking mehr für ihre projekte die können nicht nur noch verwalten und durchs verwalten ein bisschen gestalten aber große neue dinge anstoßen,
wird schwierig und,
wir verlinken dazu auch noch ein paar gute artikel aus äh von politik on europe die bei so internen geschichten aus,
brüssel eine gute quelle sind auch wenn ich diesen diesen dieser springer publikationen anderen themen nicht unbedingt
vertrauen würde
aber nochmal vielleicht ein paar fakten also es ist so dass wir nicht nur jetzt im parlament also in wir haben einerseits jetzt so die die lustige zeit in der,
solange es noch keinen neuen kommissare gibt ist die arbeitsebene,
mehr oder weniger ohne ohne aufsicht also es ist ja gerade kein kindermädchen zuhause und das heißt wenn man jetzt gerade sich mit leuten in der arbeitsebene trifft.
Was sind denn die anderen kommissare jetzt schon entlassen oder.
Sie sind noch nicht im amt die also die alte kommission von juncker ist noch im amt bis auf.
Noch jemand der.
Ja aber wenn du über neue themen sprechen willst dann hast du halt nicht wirklich jemanden der ansprech also da hast du dann sozusagen die inhaltliche sache meinung von leuten,
und du kannst dich auch mal auf einer sache eben extrem offen mit denen unterhalten.
Das heißt der apparat hat gerade etwas freiraum.
Genau und die können sich auch mal so wie sie wirklich die sachlage sehen austauschen,
der öffentlichkeit weil halt einfach noch kein sensor da ist ja das ist sowieso spannend in brüssel gerade.
Zu sensor oder zensur gesagt.
Ja vielleicht auch sein soll
ich wollte nochmal irgendwie auch ins bewusstsein rufen dass wir mit der europawahl die im maier passiert ist auch einer der größten turn on was im europaparlament gesehen haben also über sechzig prozent der,
abgeordneten sind
neu sind in ihrer ersten legislaturperiode dort und das heißt auch dass wir jetzt gerade aus netz politisch sicht ganz viele verbündete von vergangenen jahren verloren haben und ganz neu
bande wieder knüpfen müssen es ist halt einfach wirklich an viele neue gesichter viel frisches blut auch die fraktionen haben sich neu verschoben,
und dadurch wird es jetzt auf jeden fall an einem extrem eine spannende legislaturperiode.
Kennst du da noch mehr zahlen kennzahlen bezüglich der zusammensetzung.
Ja es ist der frauenanteil von siebenunddreißig a vierzig prozent gestiegen das ist gut und das alles jetzt aber eben noch mit den ganzen britischen abgeordneten das hat die frage,
wie lange die noch bleiben und sollte.
Sollte es da wirklich dazu kommen muss man sich dann eben auch nochmal anschauen welche fraktionen übrig bleiben.
Es kann sein dass ein paar gruppen sich auflösen müssen weil sie einfach niemandem mehr haben es gibt überlegungen wo jetzt also die fünf-sterne-bewegung aus italien hingeht.
Und insgesamt äh ja wird wird das eine extrem spannende kommission und man kann auch schon ein paar dinge abschätzen.
Extrem spannende kommission extrem spannendes parlament.
Extrem spannendes parlament weil eben jetzt wir wirklich neu gemischt haben und.
Gibts denn weißt du ob es neue befugnisse gibt.
Ne die regeln sind eigentlich gleich geblieben also das ist immer noch von zweitausendneun das lied.
Okay ich muss jetzt gerade nicht ob nicht irgendwas turnus gemäß vielleicht jetzt einfach beginnt oder so keine ahnung.
Ne also für den fall des brexit passiert wäre es so dass ein paar länder neue abgeordneten sitze bekommen,
weil von dem abgeordneten wird ja ein teil,
fällt weg also es werden weniger sitze im parlament sein und der großteil von diesen sitzen wird auf kleinere länder vergeben die im moment unterrepräsentiert sind von ihrer bevölkerung her,
ja genau was ich noch erzählen wollte es gibt halt auch schon ein paar,
gesetzgebung projekte die auch die kommission von der leyen angekündigt hat das eine ist die verordnung.
Was damit gemeint ist noch recht offen aber es soll eben algorithmen reguliert werden und das gesetz ist angekündigt in den ersten hundert tagen nach amtsantritt,
was das wäre jetzt eben im februar gewesen wer jetzt heute im november der amtsantritt gewesen.
Aber das wird ja nicht passieren also diese uhr simple verschoben diese verordnung ist insofern,
weil wahrscheinlich da drin auch das thema gesichtserkennung,
behandelt wird,
und es gab ankündigungen dass da auch betroffenen rechte geregelt werden sollten das ist auch ganz spannend sozusagen wenn man jetzt so thematische erkennung ist so eines der themen die,
kann man natürlich nach der datenschutzgrundverordnung behandeln aber da nochmal extra regeln zu haben die wir vielleicht sowas auch wie ein widerspruchsrecht geben oder eine besondere kennzeichnungspflicht aber vielleicht auch die,
die die die zugriffsrechte auf solche daten durch strafverfolgung behörden also das ist auf jeden fall ein netz politisch äußerst spannendes gesetz wenn es denn kommt
und eröffnet aber eben auch so die ganze frage der der regulierung von algorithmen was glaube ich ein recht neues feld ist wo
ja sehr breit diskutiert wird.
In dem zusammenhang ich weiß gar nicht ob das haben wir glaube ich auch noch nicht erwähnt linus gab es ja auch eine entscheidung kalifornien gegen die installation von gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen raum.
Hat mir das schon.
Ne das hatten wir noch nicht das machen wir nächstes mal.
Ist natürlich 'ne interessante interessante vorlage in dem zusammenhang mich einfach so ein bisschen dass sie das gleiche als allererstes durch marschieren wollen als bedeutet ja dass im prinzip schon was in der schublade haben.
Sollte es heißen also ich mein es gab eine high-level expert online die aber recht lachse empfehlungen äh vorgegeben hat
und als ich zuletzt mit leuten in der kommission geredet hab haben die eher so ja frage reingeschaut und meinten in einem
privaten vieraugengespräch nee eigentlich haben wir da noch nicht wirklich was in der schublade aber es ist es wird sicherlich texte dazu geben aber,
da ist zumindest noch nichts durchgesickert in welche richtung es gehen wird.
Ja also natürlich man kann immer irgendwie effektiv fordern und klare von solche dinge nicht diskriminieren aber wie du das konkret dann umsetzt ist 'ne 'ne ganz andere frage,
das ist das eine gesetz was uns beschäftigen wird und dann gibt es noch ein anderes thema was glaube ich hier im podcast noch nicht zur sprache kam,
dass ich aber für die größte netz politische baustelle in den nächsten jahren halte und das ist der,
sogenannte digital service act das gesetz kann man sich merken das ist die reform der e-commerce richtlinie,
die e-commerce richtlinie ist wahrscheinlich das grundlegende fundament von dem internet wie wir es heute kennen.
Ja
und ähnliche gesetze gibt es aber überall auf der welt in den usa ist,
communications diesen act worum geht's bei diesen dingen
es geht um das haftungs- privileg für roster für intermediate wäre wenn du heute über dein internet anbieter irgendwas illegales abruft dann ist dein internet anbieter nicht dafür haftbar.
Wenn du bei einem roster als kunde irgendwelche integralen inhalte ablegst dann ist auch der roster bei prinzipiell noch nicht dafür haftbar
sondern erst wenn er kenntnis von den illegalen inhalt dort bekommt,
dieses grundlegende prinzip dass du sozusagen eine privilegierung von der haftung hast als internet elias als plattform im internet
ist genau ein grundsatz der eigentlich überall in der welt anfang der zweitausender festgeschrieben wurde,
und der erst zu dem internet geführt hat wie wir es heute kennen natürlich könntest du keinen,
catching dienst kein roster und auch kein soziales netzwerk aufziehen wenn du von vornherein für alles haftbar bist was deine kunden dort ablegen könnten und du hättest vor allem auch einen starken,
präventiv dinge zu screen,
alles zu monitoren eben uploadfilter wahrscheinlich einzusetzen und im zweifelsfall ein bisschen mehr zu löschen um dann vielleicht dir der haftung zu entgehen,
weil bei solchen systemen wo du halt auch wirklich zur kasse gebeten werden könntest wenn was illegales bei dir zu finden ist,
wirst du wahrscheinlich eher mehr löschen um einfach nicht das risiko einer haftung einzugehen,
nun ja dieses e-commerce gesetz in europa gibt es seit zweitausendeins.
Und es ist eben etwas das schon sehr lange in der debatte war ob man das nicht reformieren will,
und nun dürfte die entscheidung gefallen sein nach den ankündigungen von von allein dass das in dieser legislaturperiode auch passieren wird und diese reform nennt sich eben der service act.
Und wird ziemlich sicher eine größere eine größere lobby schlacht als die datenschutzgrundverordnung und die urheberrechte richtlinie kombiniert,
weil wir haben hier die gesamte internet industrie europas die davon betroffen sein wird und zwar direkt wir haben die gesamte amerikanische internet industrie,
wir haben mal die gesamte medien,
orange alle rechte verwerten der und potenziell auch alle anderen gruppe,
die minderheiten vertreten die sich für meinungsfreiheit oder einschränkungen der meinungsfreiheit einsetzen also ich sage es immer so das ist so,
alle themen wo wir uns gefällt uns als gesellschaft nicht einig sind ob man das noch sagen darf in einen topf geworfen fest umgerührt und dann,
du globales profit orientiert das unternehmen bitte löse das jetzt für uns diese debatte wird so in der netz politischen community geführt unter dem schlagwort plattform regulierung.
Und das ist auch zumindest aus meiner sicht kann ich sagen,
das komplexes thema in der gesamten netz politischen debatte was was mir auch jemals untergekommen ist komplex,
sehr viele denkbare maßnahmen gibt in dem bereich.
Sehr sehr viele die wahrscheinlich eher schädlich als nützlich sind.
Man muss sich halt immer vorstellen wer die akteure sind die heute große internetplattformen sind die am meisten von solchen regeln betroffen sind es geht lang läufig eben auch ganz viel um die frage von,
nutzer generierten inhalten also von content moderation wie moderiere ich
die inhalte auf facebook die videos auf youtube wie funktionieren auch die empfehlung sagen für diese plattformen,
und es gibt einen bunten strauß an themen die man in dieses thema plattform regulierung oder digital service act hineingeben könnte was davon dann wirklich es in die reform schaffen wird ist noch recht offen,
und ich hab schon angedeutet wir hatten vor ein paar wochen termine mit der arbeitsebene in der kommission es gibt da auch diskussionen ob man zum beispiel ein ein thema was viele da drin sehen wollen ist in der operation
dass sich große plattformen dazu zwingen in der operative zu sein mit anderen diensten.
Die idee dahinter irgendwie mechanismen der marktmacht kommentierung zu unterbinden um ja dauerhafte konkurrenz,
möglichkeiten zu bieten den wettbewerb zu erhalten.
Daten umzug und so.
Ja also wir haben ja heute schon ein recht auf daten portabel in der datenschutzgrundverordnung aber das funktioniert noch nicht wirklich um dann auch meine daten mitzunehmen und zum konkurrenten zu gehen
bei sozialen netzwerken gibt's natürlich einen netzwerk effekt dann bin ich halt alleine auf dem neuen sozialen netzwerk,
in top qualität könnte aber genau in solchen fällen helfen dass ich vielleicht mit leuten auf whatsapp kommunizieren kann ohne direkt auf whatsapp zu sein,
das ist ein beispiel für etwas das vielleicht als ausgelagert recht aktien vielleicht zu einem interpret act dann gelöst wird wo aber ganz viele datenschutz und daten sicherheitsfragen erst zu klären sind.
Und insgesamt geht es hier viel um wettbewerbs recht auch in der daten ökonomie,
viel um die frage wie wir einfach mit,
content moderation entscheidungen umgehen die heute schon passieren und die vor allem eben auch wenn diese entscheidungen nicht unbedingt illegale inhalte betreffen wo wir ein rechtsstaatliche system haben wie man,
im endeffekt hoffentlich daran gerichtlich entscheidet ob etwas wirklich illegal ist sondern auch bei legalen inhalten ob es da überhaupt regeln braucht und wenn ja wie dieser ausschauen,
also das wird einfach nur wenn man sich vorstellt welche lobby gruppen hier beteiligt sind,
wirklich die mutter aller netz politischen schlachten das ist so meine meine prophezeiung davon.
Z
Ja und deswegen ist es wichtig sich damit
schon mal vielleicht zu beschäftigen wie wir haben das bei e center box gemacht und haben deswegen auf plattform regulation dort you mal unseren vorschlag aufgeschrieben wie
so eine plattform regulierung ausschauen sollte im rahmen der grundrechte charta der eu und was wir so als wunschliste an dieses gesetz haben
das ganze ist sehr auf politischer ebene geschrieben aber,
hoffe ich irgendwie doch für jede leute die sich da rein fuchsen wollen verständlich,
und ist halt unser beitrag jetzt mal zu der polizei debatte,
dieses gesetz wird laut aussage der kommission ungefähr ein jahr nach amtsantritt ist der frühe erste termin wo man,
mit einem gesetzesvorschlag rechnen kann vielleicht gibt es schon um den sommer herum eine konsultation,
das wichtige bei so gutem ist wenn man es schafft im vorhinein schon aktiv zu sein und im vorhinein so früh wie möglich irgendwie seine stimme
in dem prozess einzugeben dann ist es am effektivsten also dann wird hat man am ersten die chance dass die eigenen ideen auch noch umgesetzt werden bevor es zu spät ist.
Das das ist so der der grobe ausblick mal auf die eu und.
Wir haben aber auch noch andere themen die nicht im parlament oder so als gesetz abgehandelt.
Sondern auch die die die uns auch so beschäftigen und das ist die laufende reform.
Der netz neutralität ähm es ist ja so mein lieblingsthema ähm und da gibt es auch neuigkeiten,
ich glaube ich habe hier ein podcast schonmal erzählt dass die netze qualität,
ja aufgrund der regeln von zweitausendsechzehn im moment in in europa geregelt ist und diese regeln von zweitausendsechzehn werden gerade reformiert und.
Weil sie sich schon so gut durchgesetzt haben oder was.
Na ja wir haben ein paar sachen haben wir ja gesehen dass sie funktionieren und beim paar ein paar anderen wieder nicht und man muss auch sagen,
es ist nicht überall so schlimm wie in deutschland oder portugal aber wir haben vor kurzem eben
den entwurf dieser neuen regeln gesehen die sind nämlich gerade
in der konsultation also da gibt es noch bis ende november bis zum achtundzwanzigsten november die möglichkeit sich auch zu beteiligen
diese konzentration wird gemacht von berg der name kennt man vielleicht noch wenn man damals zugehört hat das ist das gremium der telekom regulierung behörden,
in europa also der zusammenschluss von bundesnetzagentur und r und dieses gremium gibt eben die guideline heraus dass es sowas wie der
der implementierung leitfaden für die qualität gesetze in europa.
Bevor du bevor du ausholt und was sich sozusagen jetzt ändern soll bespricht würd mich ja nochmal ganz kurz interessieren wie du eigentlich,
bisher so zufrieden bist insbesondere mich nochmal aktueller blick auf die situation mit der telekom und on.
Interessieren weil da gab 's ja nur einige bewegungen die wir zwar hier diskutiert haben aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere nicht mit dir.
Das war ja immer deine voraussagen dass das da ärger geben wird es gab es ärger aber stream on gibt's ja immer noch.
Ja also das was ich schon eigentlich im april zweitausendsiebzehn als dieses produkt rauskam kritisiert habe,
ist jetzt mehr als zwei jahre später auch gerichtlich festgestellt,
und zwar nämlich dass dieses produkt der deutschen telekom ganz klar gegen die regelungen verstößt diese
ausstellung auf dvd qualität bei video streams ist einfach nicht ob da argumentiert war im rahmen der eu gesetze und der zweite starke kritikpunkt war immer dass sie vom roaming ausgenommen sind also dass du streamen und nur innerhalb von deutschland nutzen kannst und nicht auch im europäischen ausland
bei den zwei punkten waren wir uns immer hundertprozentig sicher die haben wir jetzt auch,
richtig bestätigt bekommen das sind auch die zwei punkte
die die bundesnetzagentur in ihrer entscheidung überhaupt den produkt vorgeworfen hat die kernfrage.
Und das ist jetzt auch behoben worden.
Genau also da haben wir jetzt eben also hat die bundesnetzagentur sich mit der deutschen telekom gestritten über,
äh glaube ich viel gerichte hinweg und zwei instanzen an meinem ein verfahren und einmal eine normale verfahren und jetzt glaube ich noch zwei jahren ist das ein verfahren endlich entschieden und dadurch ist der aber die aufschieben die wirkung dieses einspruch der deutschen telekom,
nicht mehr da und sie mussten das produkt jetzt anpassen aber eben nur in diesen zwei punkten bei der drosselten und beim roaming die kernfrage des readings,
die hat sich die bundesnetzagentur nicht mal getraut auf zu werfen,
sowie bei der frage des rating s fast keine regulierung behörde in europa bisher den mut hatte so ein produkt mal wirklich zu verbieten,
also wir haben noch fast keine gerichtliche entscheidung zu sehr rating weil schon auf regulatorischen ebene den willen bei den behörden nicht gibt dieses thema überhaupt anzufassen.
Warum nicht.
Weil jeder behörde die das anfasst sofort
im rampenlicht in ganz europa stehen würde und diese entscheidung dann höchst gerichtlich zu klären wäre das lustige ist wir haben trotzdem eine entscheidung aus ungarn jetzt dann bald die auch sie rating betreffen wird
aber die ist zustande gekommen ohne dass die regulierung behörde versucht hat ein produkt zu verbieten es wurde einfach in einem gerichtsprozess die frage aufgeworfen wie das zu lesen wäre
und das gericht hat die frage dann an den eugh verwiesen ich kann gern das verfahren verlinken das ist,
von ende zwei achtzehn und wird ein jener zwei neunzehn in zwei achtzehn war das und das wird auch nochmal ein bisschen rechtliche klarheit bringen weil das rechtlich so,
unklar in der verordnung geregelt ist hat sich noch keine behörde getraut auf basis dieses unklaren gesetzes eine entscheidung zu treffen.
Also ich vermute mal innerhalb innerhalb dieser reform diskussion ist das einer der punkte die dann auch aufgegriffen werden aufgegriffen werden müssen.
Genau also was was rating da in der reform drin steht es recht spannend weil das ist großteils das was wir gefordert haben aber nur ein teil der miete.
Also was jetzt schon in den vorschlägen.
Genau was schon jetzt.
Gefordert habt was habt ihr denn gefordert.
Also wir haben gefordert dass es klare nicht diskriminierung regeln gibt also wenn du schon sehr rating machst ja und das ist schon.
Für uns etwas dass wir lieber nicht in der welt sehen würden weil eigentlich gibt's da gibt es keinen grund für sie rating aber wenn du es schon machst dann musst du es wenigstens so machen dass du,
allen diensten ein apps erlaubst teil von dem rating programm zu sein und nicht nur auswählst ich habe hier whatsapp und ich habe hier youtube,
und dann darf sich der kunde eine von den zwei apps aussuchen sondern dass du sagst ich habe hier die kategorie messaging dienste,
an die sind irgendwie alle messungen dienste die sich bei mir melden werden hier aufgenommen oder du hast video dienste und das ist dann halt nicht nur youtube sondern auch wie mir,
diese art von offenen klassen passierten rating ist das was berg,
jetzt in den neuen regeln festzuschreiben will und auch recht spezifisch sich auslöst darüber
was ein telekom unternehmen tun muss um so eine
ein offenes klassen passiert des rating programm nicht diskriminieren zu machen zum beispiel das ist nichts kosten dafür die app wenn sie teilnimmt an diesen dingen und das eben alle erlaubt sein sollen wenn sie die formalen kriterien erfüllen.
Aber wer stellt die kriterien für diese klasse dann auf das wird ja schwierig meine messenger videos training das mag noch einfach klingen ist aber im detail schwierig insbesondere wenn ihr jetzt eine app raushaust die sozusagen alles macht
was irgendwo gesehen rettet ist ja wieso messages kannst du bei uns auch versenden und wir streamen auch mal video so und dann dann ist alles gesehen rettet.
Ja
das ist genau das problem dass du recht arbeit faire kategorien am ende hast und ein ein messenger kann auch videobotschaften verschicken kann sogar video kreuz machen ist es jetzt video oder messaging oder es ist die kategorie social die oft auch nochmal gibt
das ist alles nicht sauber getrennt und es verstößt auch alles gegen die grundsätze des des des netzes dass du eben nicht mehr
ende zu ende hast sondern du kaufst halt statt einem zugang zu einem universellen netz an social paket oder ein video paket und
das bricht an der universität der dienste die über das netz angeboten werden an versucht hat er so einen jetzigen markt zustand festzuschreiben.
Ja und vor allem es geht auch nur von den kategorien aus dies heute gibt und erlaubt in dem sinne ja genau das nicht was man ja eigentlich durch dich dieses verbot von seo rettung erreichen möchte nämlich neuartige apps
zu oder dienste überhaupt zu
ermöglichen den quasi vom start weg keine limitierung zu geben damit sie eben irgendwie auch ein neues paradigma auf den tisch legen können und nicht unbedingt jetzt nur in demselben spiel mitmachen und dem mein rosig signifikant unterscheidet,
ob er überhaupt zu zahlen auch diese markt attraktivität zu haben wenn man dann,
aus allen klassen heraus fällt weil die halt bisher noch keiner gedacht hat dann ist es bald bei sicher dazu entspannt.
Ja und das ganze bricht sowieso an vielen stellen also einerseits sogar
die die kategorien von den an produkten von ein und derselben anbieter unterscheiden sich wurde von pass was es hier in deutschland gibt hat in griechenland zum beispiel auch einen maps pass wo dann irgendwie google und apple maps dazu buchen kannst
gibt es in keinem anderen land
du hast auch wenn du denkst ja die app muss sich nur einmal melden und dann ist sie teil von dem rating programm gut das heißt aber du musst dich,
tausenden internet provider melden in europa alleine um dann,
in den rating angeboten in ganz europa vertreten zu sein das kannst du als kleines startup nicht leisten,
ist auch technisch gar nicht machbar weil du musst ja verträge unterzeichnen du hast,
falls du es nicht schaffst dass du den vorher bescheid gibst wenn du was an deinem dienst änderst du bist haftbar für,
festlich verbuchen des datenvolumen von den kunden und so also das sind alles ideen die nicht skalieren und die komplett dem widersprechen wofür das internet mal gedacht wurde ja und das nur damit du weiter rating machen kannst und,
eigentlich rating über den abschaffen der datenvolumen zu lösen aber.
Sei es drum was berg hier vorschlägt ist halt einfach klare regeln wie man eben solche offenen klassen basierten systeme nicht diskriminierend macht,
und wir haben ihn da ein paar tipps gegeben auch in dem workshop den wir im mai hatten mit ihnen sie haben alte.
Wir haben da mal was vorbereitet.
Ja das kernproblem.
Ich habe da so ein digitalpakt vorbereitet.
Das problem ist halt so wir haben eigentlich immer für ein verbot von sehr rating argumentiert und,
dann haben wir halt irgendwann mal gesagt okay aber diese probleme haben auch diese art von neuesten art von von netzer qualitätsverbesserungen,
und genau den teil haben sie aufgegriffen aber die andere kritik haben sie leider ignoriert ja also wir würden uns auch wünschen dass wenigstens mal die rating angebote verboten werden wo,
eben wirklich nur einzelne dienste heraus gegriffen werden und dann eben wirklich nur youtube und whatsapp,
zum angebot zur verfügung stehen und die mehrzahl der rating angebote in europa sind genauso geschlossenen wo du wirklich nur eine,
selection apps hast die der provider selber ausgesucht und co rabattiert hat.
Ich habe eine idee für ein kompromiss man also wenn man einzelne apps zulässt muss man alle anderen apps die mit demselben buchstaben anfangen auch zu lassen.
Da gibt's einfach nur sechsundzwanzig kategorien fertig und die chinesen fliegen raus.
Die konzentration live noch tim bitte bringen diesen vorschlag eigentlich das sehr.
Das ist juni nicole basierte rassismus auf digital wegen.
Es zeigt wie aber das ganze ist.
Ja also wir wir haben wir haben auf jeden fall mal rating als thema sind aber noch ein paar andere dinge die uns,
der,
dass das andere wichtige thema ist im moment haben wir in den letzten drei tipps regeln ein klares verbot von inspection,
du darfst das telekom betreiber nicht in den von transport leer vorgehen also du darfst nicht tief in die pakete hineinschauen da wo es wirklich um die inhalte geht von dem was die nutzer gerade in deinem netz machen das darfst du dir nicht mal anschauen,
und genau dieses verbot von die berge wollen sie aufheben.
Mit welchem argument.
Gar keinen es gibt keines ist das gesetz dass sie ja hier nur implementieren ist gleich geblieben die technik hat sich nicht verändert und es gibt auch keinen text in dem entwurf der guideline der jetzt konfrontiert wird der sich geändert hat.
Also alles was da passiert ist es gibt einen massiven druck von der industrie.
Von telekom betreibern und von cisco dass man unbedingt die bäcker inspection erlauben soll,
aber sie haben sich nicht mal auf einen entwurf geeinigt wie dieses packet inspection verbot ab geändert werden sollte und deswegen ist das so einer der punkte wo der fisch eindeutig stinkt und wo wir glauben dass wir,
gute argumente haben,
aber überhaupt dass man diese frage aufwirft über das tip act inspection verbot nochmal zu diskutieren zeigt schon dass hier gerade sehr starke industrie einfluss am am am werk ist und,
doch da wo es keine argumente gibt man versucht nochmal neu zu verhandeln.
Was denkst du was die industrie denn da tun möchte mit p ich meine was.
Einerseits eben auch für angebote wenn du überlegst was du jetzt hier ganz viele neue apps willst,
dann musst du dir auch irgendwie erkennen dass das jetzt diese diese app ist und wenn du aber ein shirt huster hast oder keine defiziten alpi adressen für dein dienst verwendest,
dann wirst du auf.
Domain oder urls zurückgreifen als kriterium um herauszufinden dass dieses daten paket jetzt zu einem retteten dienst gehört und deswegen anders gezählt werden muss,
und gleichzeitig ist es für sie auch glaube ich ein thema von verkehrs management das was die deutsche telekom gemacht hat mit der russel war ja auch nur mit die inspection möglich dass du jetzt hier irgendwie,
beliebige video dienste erkennst und die dann drosselten auf die vor die qualität,
wirst du auch nicht nur mit einer erkennen einer erkennung aufgrund von alpi adressen hinbekommen sondern du wirst du auch in die pakete hineinschauen müssen um festzustellen okay das ist jetzt hier diese video streaming dienst,
von der domain oder mit der url und dann werde ich den anders behandeln.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob das reinschauen wirklich noch so viel bringen wird in der zukunft wenn zunehmenden maße die daten ströme dann auch wirklich,
mal verschlüsselt sind.
Mit techniken wie essen einzelunternehmerin definition kannst du ja trotzdem noch auf die domain schließen,
und die funktionieren auch wenn das eine verschlüsselte verbindung ist dass es mitunter auch genau einer fragen die berge aufwirft in der.
Ja und ist das betrachten von meter daten schon die inspektion weil ich mein dann schaust du ja nicht wirklich ins paket rein.
Passiert auf leer fünf bis sieben und damit bist du klar schon in dem bereich der in der definition von inspection.
Ja naja ich denke mal wird nicht mehr so lange dauern und dann hast du irgendwann auch irgendwelche steine in den raum drin und dann wird sozusagen einfach das protokoll an den pattern erkannt wie die plakate pakete hin und her
fliegen ohne dass wir da groß auf dem leer reinschauen.
Es gibt auch schon solche debatten rund um die touristik dass du dass du erkennst welche art von traffic das ist nur anhand der frequenz und größer der daten pakete
das problem ist aber auch hier die hohe fehler anfälligkeit was ist wenn du neue innovative dienste hast die einfach ein anderes pattern haben und dann hast du volles positives dabei
also auch die ganze idee man könnte klassen passiert des verkehrs management machen indem man errät welche art von dienst das jetzt,
es geht halt von der falschen annahme aus dass es eine endliche anzahl von von internet anwenden
wenn du nur irgendwie grob darauf schaust wirst du schon erraten können was das jetzt ist,
aber das sind halt alles annahmen die werden brechen weil die innovationsfreude fähigkeit im netz ähnlich groß und wachsend ist wie sie das bisher war.
Ja dann haben wir noch andere themen
control also jugendschutz filter und andere sperre listen sind auch etwas dass wir gerade erstreiten müssen dass das verboten bleibt in dieser reform im moment ist es so dass,
kontos filter und auch andere arten von,
filtern dass du zum beispiel auch was nicht ein halal internet oder eine granny internet oder ein besonderes jugend freundliches internet oder auch im internet wo spieler websites gesperrt sind
all diese optionalen filter funktionieren im moment nicht die sind,
ausgeschlossen du kannst nicht in den geschäftsbedingungen für ein internet produkt
sagen dass du gewisse teile des internets von vornherein spürst so eine sperrung hat nach dem bestehenden regeln auf dem endgerät selber zu passieren.
Wer auch jeder jugendschutz filter wenn er klug ist nicht bei deiner mobilfunk und passiert sondern auf dem gerät selber,
weil ansonsten muss das kind nur zu mcdonald's gehen und dort ins wlan um den jugendschutz filter zu umgehen das sollte ein no-go rainer sein dieses thema haben wir auch eigentlich schon auf gesetzgeberische ebene
zweitausendfünfzehn endgültig behandelt als wir im trilogie es geschafft haben dass solche brandl control filter rausgestrichen wurden aus dem text
trotzdem und auch ohne jeden wirklichen grund hat berg dieses thema in der reform nochmal neu aufgeworfen und versucht jetzt gerade,
da eine sehr holprigen rechtliche konstruktion.
Um solche optionalen spezialisten doch noch zu ermöglichen,
auch hier vermute ich massiven lobby druck aus der industrie,
das ist einfach eine neue art wie man internet produkte differenzieren kann
dass es halt eben nicht nur eine reine dann pipe ist nicht nur ein simpler zugangs dienst und äh ja auch hier werden wir kämpfen müssen,
und zuletzt hab ich noch ein thema wo wir hoffentlich nicht kämpfen müssen weil ich glaube dass wir gewonnen haben und dass es fünf g,
fünf g ist der.
Werden wir auch verlieren wir haben da schon zweige nicht gewonnen haben wir gewonnen.
Ich rede nicht von deutschen.
Kennst du ja äh hier steht ja oben weil wir offen alphonso match.
Bei mir steht immer für germany.
Ähm.
Ich werde mich nicht mehr zur deutschen mobilfunknetze äußern.
Ja auch nicht.
Ich ja aber fünf g ist ist es nicht.
Hallo thomas ist gut netz politik.
Gut gut gut.
Ja spürbar vor.
Fünf g insofern spannend für die netze qualität weil es neue technologie aspekte bringt
die genannten networks leistung und edge computing und das ist eine herausforderung für die qualität,
network slice erlauben mehr,
der name schon sagt das netzwerk in einzelnen schichten zu unterteilen die unterschiedliche qualitätsfaktor risiken haben also ich kann,
networks likes haben der ist besonders,
breiten optimiert oder besonders niedriger latenz besonders hohe verfügbarkeit oder besonders niedriger energieverbrauch.
Geh mal netten streaming netten also eine sache und das
ist ja auch technische vollkommen nachvollziehbar dass man unterschiedliche anforderungen profiler hat insbesondere in punkto so kleine geräte lampen und so weiter die alle irgendwie rum funken und nur so ein bisschen die liefern
das will man halt irgendwie garantiert haben sollte von dem restlich gestellt werden braucht aber nicht so viel bandbreite aber es hat halt irgendwie 'ne andere administrative domäne und so weiter.
Und weil das technische jetzt möglich ist mit fünf g ich meine es war optional auch als feature bei vier geht schon drin in abgespeckte form,
und das ist deswegen spannend weil wir in keiner anderen weltregionen gerade versuchen diese frage zu beantworten die usa haben keine netzwerk qualität mehr sind aber massiv beim ausbau
kanada und indien haben gute netzwerk qualitäts regeln aber noch keine fünf g das thematik dort und südkorea hat vor kurzem die die dortigen netzwerk qualitäts regeln
fünf g aufgehoben also haben sogenannte regulatorisches box gemacht in der sie das thema,
fünf g sozusagen reinlegen und die die bestehenden telekom der bestehende telekom rechtsrahmen gilt sozusagen für diese neue technik,
somit ist europa die erste weltregionen die versucht die zwei dinge auf einen nenner zu bringen und deswegen sind die regeln wie sie hier gemacht werden auch,
vielleicht von größerer tragweite.
Und was wir was wir halt hier immer,
von den nutzern selber gesteuert werden sollen das heißt du hast als,
kunde die wahl welche app jetzt auf welchen networks leise laufen soll man kann sich das so vorstellen ich habe mobiltelefon mit einer sim-karte und da habe ich mehrere networks leistet drauf.
Und dann ist die frage welche app von meinem telefon verwendet jetzt welchen networks.
Und genau diese entscheidung sagt berg muss eben bei den kunden selber liegen und muss der kontrolle sein und das soll nicht der telekom betreiber sagen okay die app die mir am meisten zahlt kommt jetzt den schnelleren networks.
An dass es immer wofür wir argumentiert haben und das findet sich auch in der jetzigen regelung zu fünf g networks lives in dem dorf der guideline.
Wir werden uns da auf jeden fall mit einer einer einreichung beteiligen und werden das sehr genau beobachten und die finalen regeln werden dann im märz zwanzig zwanzig
beschlossen sein und dann wissen wir wie es mit der zentralität in europa weiter.
Genau denn
alles was jetzt in irgendwelchen entwürfen drin steht kann am ende auf herausfliegen und da haben wir auch schon einige battles gesehen in dieser hinsicht aber ist ja schon weiß auch nicht so schlecht wenn vom stadtwerk schon mal was ganz brauchbar was drin steht das haben wir ja auch nicht immer.
Also wir haben auch schon irgendwie im mai das erste mal in brüssel mit denen gestritten und das wird auf jeden fall eine spannende debatte bleiben zuletzt hab ich noch eine eine positive nachricht.
Noch eine oh moin moin moin moin moin moin.
Aux
Rekord jetzt schon das zweite mal schalten sie auch das nächste mal ein sie thomas lohne bei.
Nur eine genau nur eine pro stunde.
Das ist schon eine ganz gute quote wir waren auch schon mal auf so eine pro quartal.
Ja wer sich erinnert der post skandal in österreich,
haben wir mit der plattform eigentum damals aufgedeckt da hat die österreichische post,
die partei affinität von der bevölkerung in österreich errechnet aber mehr so daumen mal piep und diese daten über politische präferenz dann verkauft an wahlwerbung parteien
und das gab eine sehr große welle weil das die leute natürlich gestört hat dass die post hier irgendwie dich zum fdp ö oder grünen wähler macht,
und daraufhin haben wir gleich gesagt okay weil das die leute stört wäre es doch wichtig wenn sie mal wissen,
was denn ihre errechnet die partei affinität ist und dann haben sie haben wir auch wieder formulare für auskunft ersuchen zur verfügung gestellt
die sehr sehr viele leute verwendet haben das hat dazu geführt dass die post auch wieder komplett überlastet war diese ganzen datenschutz auskunft ersuchen,
zu bearbeiten.
Das auch eure tennisball maschine ne ja ja papa papa papa papa.
Wenn du daten sammelst dann musst du dich auch irgendwie an die betroffenen rechte halten und weil dann eben so viele leute bei uns ankam und sagten ich habe immer noch nicht meine daten bekommen,
online gestellt dass die eigene daten noch nicht gekommen sind.
All das hat bei der datenschutz behörde jetzt ein größeres puff verfahren ausgelöst das letzte woche mit einer großen überraschung geendet ist nämlich eine achtzehn millionen strafe für die österreichische post
für dieses datenschutz vergehen der gesamten
partei raffiniert it und eben auch glaube ich der fehlenden auskunft praxis das ist jetzt angesichts des fast zwei milliarden umsatz von der österreichischen post noch kein existenzbedrohend oder
keine existenzbedrohend strafe dieser.
Umsatz hat das ja nichts zu tun was ist denn der gewinn.
Das fragst du mich jetzt zu früh weil das.
Na ja weil umsatz irgendwas sein frage ist wie viel kohle haben die gemacht äh bestimmt keine zwei milliarden euro.
Ich habe jetzt hier den umsatz rausgesucht weil sich die strafen aufgrund der datenschutzgrundverordnung ja an dem umsatz berechnen.
Na ja klar aber letzten endes die wie sehr sie trifft das.
Da hast du recht ja.
Und jetzt sich dann doch eher daran ne.
Das habe ich jetzt auf die auf anhieb nicht gefunden in der recherche aber es ist auf jeden fall datenschutzbehörden.
Nochmal.
Und trotzdem sind diese achtzehn millionen die größte strafe die österreichische datenschutz behörde jemals erlassen hat,
oft insofern ist das ein ganz
spannender toller fall und da wollte ich einfach nur mal sagen dass das jetzt hier zumindest einen guten abschluss gefunden hat auch wenn die post glaube ich angekündigt hat dass sie in berufung gehen wird.
Wenn sie noch geld überhaupt um da zu bezahlen.
Ja davon gehe ich aus leider.
Gut das war schon fast mit den inhaltlichen ich wollte nur mal irgendwie ganz kurz anführen dass wir gerade auf.
Warte mal ergebnis vortrag steuern zwanzig achtzehn post äh hundertsiebenundneunzig gemacht also zweihundert millionen das heißt.
Bist du mit fast.
Es sind so neun.
Es tut schon.
Klingelt schon ein bisschen das klingt schon ein bisschen.
Da würde ich auch gegen klagen.
Ja
also man sieht wir sind aktiv auf vielen fronten deswegen suchen wir auch unterstützung,
hat gerade eine stelle ausgeschrieben die ich ganz spannend findet nämlich wir brauchen jemanden der uns hilft kampagnen,
bei der umsetzung der eu rechts rechtlinie zu koordinieren man erinnert sich vielleicht noch in den kampf gegen upload-filter und leistungsschutzrecht,
genau dieses eu gesetz war eine richtlinie die muss in allen eu-mitgliedstaaten umgesetzt werden
und um diese umsetzung zu begleiten und positiv zu beeinflussen an wie ein projekt am laufen und da brauchen wir eine karenz vertretung von januar bis mai,
oder jena bis juni glaub ich da steht alles in der verlinken stellenausschreibung wo ihr euch noch bewerben könnt jetzt im november insofern bitte,
auch mit mir gemeinsam an der netz politik arbeiten könnt dann,
jetzt gerade eure gelegenheit und,
wer nicht bei uns anhören will aber trotzdem ein t-shirt haben will oder andere gut ist wir haben noch eine aktion laufen wo man fördermitglied werden kann bis zum zehnten november und dann kriegt man dieses jahr noch irgendwie seine gutes zugeschickt,
weil wir machen das ja alles nicht mehr nur als hobby sondern als berufung.
Erfolgreiche datenschützer bei dir in der region rufen sie jetzt an.
Reporter ohne grenzen sucht auch noch eine
stelle oder hat eine stelle und sucht eine besetzung zwar als referentin für internetfreiheit in berlin die aufmerksamkeiten unter euch werden sich erinnern es gar nicht so lange ist
her ist dass wir diese stelle schon mal hier beworben haben,
das tun wir jetzt nochmal arbeitsbereich informationsfreiheit im internet soll verantwortet werden ihr kennt reporter ohne grenzen setzen sich weltweit,
online wie offline für presse meinungs- und informationsfreiheit ein und unterstützen natürlich auch medienschaffenden in,
notsituation das wäre ein job in berlin vielleicht auch für die eine oder andere hörerinnen interessant.
Und das bringt uns jetzt zu den termin.
Aux
Vom zweiundzwanzigsten bis vierundzwanzigsten november findet in bremen die pfiff konferenz zwanzig neunzehn statt und zwar unter dem motto,
als wunderland alle interessierten sind herzlich eingeladen eintritt ist frei,
infos gibt's natürlich auch auf zwanzig neunzehn punkt pfiff korn de ist nicht schwer nicht einfach zu schreiben punkt de.
Da könnt ihr euch informieren eintritt frei zweiundzwanzigster bis vierundzwanzigster november in bremen.
Ja und ansonsten steht erstmal nichts weiter an ja auf dem terminkalender zumindest haben wir keine weitere kenntnis,
oder wir haben eure termine einreichung bei uns schlicht übersehen ignoriert oder absichtlich gelöscht.
Das machen wir eigentlich nie wir haben ja sogar sogar die rein die wir nicht ankündigen sollen.
Guck mal hier so für termine.
Ich kann auch einbringen am siebten november haben wir den vierzigsten netz politischen abend in wien mit ganz spannenden themen siehst du kriegst du noch lokal koloriert.
Noch mehr.
Ist das jetzt die längste sendung die wir jemals hatten.
Weiß ich gar nicht wenn ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher aber ich gucke mal nach während du dein ab gesang.
Ja möchtest du die termine die noch beenden oder was.
Achso ja kann ich auch mal ja klar.
Okay ich frag mal.
Ja es ist ja in ordnung.
Ja dann werden wir am ende der sendung angelangt danke thomas danke götz und.
Genau und auch auf anderen wege unterstützen so ist nicht die längste sendung wir beide wir beide haben schon mal locker drei stunden zwei minuten drei stunden und drei schon drei minuten durch.
Wann war das wohl zu welchen welche folgen.
Unglück im glück im unglück war die längste bisher das war nochmal zweihundertdrei und bedenken second war nur eine minute kürzer also.
Die till sind gar nicht so schlecht.
Irgendwie ruft es immer interessante erinnerung vor allerdings ist jetzt diese sendung glaube ich wirklich dann auch auf platz drei.
Wer wird es aber nicht das war jetzt mal ein längeres update wir wissen noch nicht so ganz genau ob nächste woche dann gleich was ist der herr geschossen kommen kann.
Wenn dann kommt's und wenn ich dann kommt später so bis dahin.
Ciao ciao.
Aux